[콧방귀] 안녕하십니까 체물텐
여러분. 행복한 투자 회정을 함께하는
체슬리 모닝 브리프 6월 29일
월요일입니다. 주말 잘 보내셨습니까?
일부 시작하겠습니다. 먼저 전일
금요일 중국 시장 왕정부장님과 함께
알아보겠습니다.
>> 네. 그 아시아 증시 동반하라 하면서
상 지수 -2.25%는 빠졌고요.
흥성체 지수는 -3.4% 4%
빠졌습니다. 정시 거대면 삼중 요조
외까지 올라하고요. 업종별 보시면은
부동자 에너지 업종이 선대적으로
강세포였지만 커뮤니케이션 수제 산업제
업정이 약세되었습니다.
지난주 금요일 거 배당 방어주디
관련주들이 올라왔습니다. 장금 청년
1.25% 올라고 환 수는 1.4%
구토 청년의 영적은 5% 올라왔어요.
그리고 소비 승소지 그리고 주조환
정책 강화 등용으로 가정 관련주도
판단했습니다. 디면 2.7% 정도
올라왔어요. 글로벌 반도체 업체 케파
케파 확대 등 기다음으로 IT
점유주들이 강세되었습니다. 법화
화천는 1.9% 오라고 종도세를
3.5% 올라하고 점천 타이크는
1.5% 올라왔습니다.
요리선 공급 보조에 따라서가 추가
인상 등 기담으로 관영주들이 아마
1주인 내 계속 올라왔어요. 충구
거선은 추가적으로 자증 7% 올라고
홍화 테크는 7% 중대 테크 5%
화트는 300% 오라고요. 이번 주
그 CCR가 추가 인상 여보에 주문할
필요가 있고요. 아마 킨보드가
[콧방귀]
>> 그 수요일 목일 아마 가격 인상
가능성이 있습니다. 시장 기대치는
10%보다 15% 정도 되고 있고요.
뭐가 15% 인상하면 되게 베스트
시나리오로 될 수 있습니다.
>> 회사한테.
>> 네. 맞아요. 증체 업이 업종에
대해서 큰 허제로 적용할 수
있습니다.
>> 태양구 관련주도 강세 보였고요. 어
전승 기전은 3.3% 우하고 DCR
종화는 10% 상가 기록했습니다.
반면은 A의 관연수 다소 다수
빠졌습니다. 승인테크는 자증 7%
빠졌고 호전 주신는 5% 중제 5천
5% 신 역는 73 7.3%
빠졌습니다. 어 신념물 구체 금리
0.8PB이 8b했습니다. 인연물
구체 금리는 -1.2bp 하라고
외양화 환율 염
소폭 전라되었습니다.
>> 감사합니다. [콧방귀]
중국 시장은 요즘 중국도 어 중국도
한국처럼 월별 전략 아니면 뭐 주관
시황 일별 어 시황 이런 자료들이
증권사에서 나옵니까?음
>> 군의 증권사인가요? 아니, 중국에
중국 시장에 대해서 중국 아, 네.
네. 네. 커먼트가 좀이긴 있습니다.
>> 그럼 요즘에 중국은 그런 최적으로
단기라고 볼 수 있는
>> 뭐 일주일이나 아니면 한 달
>> 정도 제일 관심 있는 어떤 이슈가
뭐예요?
>> XMT 성장하는 겁니다.
>> 아, TXMT.
>> 네. 네. 맞아요. CXMT.
>> TXMT죠? 예. C
>> CXMT 창신 매물 네신
>> 관련해서 어 관심이 있다는 거는
얼마나 증시에 큰 수급적 임팩트를 줄
거냐 아니면 올라오면 시가 총액이가
어떻게 형성이 될 거냐 뭐 그런
건가?
>> 예. 맞습니다.
>> 관련해서는 그럼 전체적으로 어 중국
시장에 투자하고 있는 이미 투자하고
있는 분들께는
>> 네.
>> 어 CXMT 상장이
>> 호재입니까? 악제입니까? 단계적으로
>> 어
뭐 이거 얘기가 좀 많고요. 섹스엠티
성장하면은 약간 수급 이슈가 좀
발산할 수 있어요.
>> 음
>> 왜냐면 지금 완 전내는 타켓 빨리가음
>> 거의 3조 외 정도 되는데 요즘에
5조부터 7조까지도 보고 있습니다.
10조까지도 얘기하고 있어요. 10조
반 하면은 정찰 시가 총을 왕락
계산하면 2천 2,조 정도 됩니다.
2천조
>> 음
>> 가능성도 있긴 있어요. 왜냐면
[목을 가다듬음] 내년은 40조 정도
벌 수 있으니까 정체 충구 반도체
업체는 다 거의 다 50배 이상
바고이잖아요.
>> 그래도 개사하면 10조 나올 수
있어요.
>> 10조 나오면은 금방도 쉬자마자 거좀
나올 수 있어요. 내주가 왜냐면 당일
상승하 뭐 상한가 한가 없어요.
>> 그래서 맞아요. 그래서 IPO는 보통
이렇게 되면 요통 주식수 그렇게 많지
않으니까 당일나 아마 두 세배 정도
우라할 수 있어요. 갈까? 그래서이
수급 인간 좀 크고요. 20조 10조
하면은 정체 충구 정치에서 차지할
비료는 10% 넘어갈 수 있어요. 그
영향은 좀 크고요. 이외는이 호사는
자분 조화가 되면은 정비주 최대 수고
수 있습니다. 왜냐면 자기 받은 돈
바로 그 밑에 정비 홀사를 투자해야
되고요. 정비도 구입하고 그래서
요즘에 정비 좋으라 하는 이유가
그거기 때문입니다. 그렇습니다.
CXMT 상장일이 정확히
정해졌습니까? 어 지난주 금요일
업데이트 되는 내용 중 있습니다. 어
7월 이길 때는 아마 최종적으로 그
보고서나 제출 마무리 되는 거
같고요. 그래서 7월 두제부터는 자은
무지 청약네 하고 최종 성장하면은
7월 말입니다.네
>> 지금 나오는 얘기가 이렇게 되고
있습니다.
>> 알겠습니다. 전에 2,조 정도라고
언뜻 말씀해 주셨는데 어 이익 규모는
삼성전자나 하이닉스 대비 좀 많이
낮지만 멀티플을 높게 받으니까
>> 시가 총액은 거의 또 비슷하게 일단
형성이 될 수도 있겠다.
>> 그런 말씀 전해 주셨습니다.
>> 네.
>> 예. 이슈 종목 볼 텐데요. 어.
>> 네. 입신청일까?
>> 정밀 맞습니까?
>> 네. 이심 맞아요. 최근에 많이
>> 어 금요일 알고 지난주 그 초 뭐
수요일인가 화요일 그대는 한번
소개했는데네 맞아요. 또 관력
[목을 가다듬음] 리포트 하나
나왔습니다. 입신점 지난주 금요일
매너스 9% 정도 맞았어요. 충구
시전은 매너 10% 하한가이니까 거의
한가가 갔습니다.
>> 그 관련 코멘트 리퍼드 나왔고요.
일단 그 실조는 뭐 전에 다 나오고
태배한 거 없고요. 어이 빠지는
이유는 애플 때문에요. 어 GP 워크
리포트 보면은 애플는 매북 그리고
애패드 가격 인상에 따라서 판매량
감소 우려로 주가는 구퍼스는 좀
빠졌습니다. 다만 아이폰 가격을
유지하고요. 최근에 공금한 저
대사하다라면 원래는 아이폰 출화
가시성 제품 믹스 개선이 확긴되면서
하라는 과도한 방인걸로 판단되었고요.
>> 음
>> 어 아이폰 출환 시장 예선시 대비도
성호할 가능성 좀 있고요. 그리고
거가 제품 비중 프로맥스 있잖아요.이
이 부분은 매출비 좀 확대하고
있습니다. 따라서 동사는 마진을 개선
가능성이 있습니다. 이번에 원래
하반기부터 8배주 1유t티 컨트레시버
출화 예정이고요. 음
>> 원래부터 내년 내후년 통신 장비 사업
매출는 동의망하고
있습니다. 전에는 그 거사스 리퍼드도
나오잖아요. 거사스도 비슷하게 보고
있습니다.이 기어도는 각각 10%
12% 정도 예상하고 있습니다. 음
따라서 원래 내년 내 홍년 순위 있는
각가 213억 280억 370억
위한로 추정되었고 지전 대비 1%
4% 11% 정도 상승했어요. 타케도
내년 그 25배 적용하면 TP는
97을 위한 정도가 세시했습니다.
지전 대비는 18% 정도 상승을 하고
지난주 금밀 중가 대비는 40%
업세도 나올 수 있어요.
>> 음.
우리 [콧방귀] 하여튼 하루 이틀
전에 해 주셨던 종목인데 다시 해
주셨던 거는 지난주 목요일인가요? 그
미국에서 애플이 -6% 정도 되면서
>> 어 제가 유리프로랑 그때
>> 어 가격을 올려도 그래도 또 우리
애플 이렇게 충성 고객들은 그냥 사지
않을까라는 말씀을 드렸던 기억이
있는데
>> 실제로 시장에서는 아 이제 애플은
가격 올리면 수요가 줄어든다라는
걱정을 일부 하시기도 하는 거
같습니다.
>> 맞아요. 아이폰는 유지했어요.
왜냐면이 회사는 주요 사업은
아이폰이잖아요.
맵크 이런 거는 다 회사 뭐 의해서
승차하고 있어요. 최근에 제가 좀
주변한 사람이한테 물어보니까 맥부
애드 이런 가격화에 좀 뭐 뭐 디래할
수 가능성이 있다고 생각해. 교체
그거 수요가
>> 아과 나머지 애플 제품들은 좀
다르다. 수요의 탄력성이.
>> 맞아. 맞아요. 가격은 많이
인상했어요.
>> 음.
>> 다만 그 주말에 나오는 이슈가 그
아이폰을 또 추가적으로 CXMT는
매물리 살 수 있다고 그렇게 얘기해서
나누고 있으니까
>> 사실 뭐 진청되지 않을까 싶어요.
>> 네.
>> 알겠습니다. 이게 또 근데 또 가격은
한번 이렇게 올려 놓으면 시간이
지나면 그게 또 베이스 가격이 돼서
>> 맞습니다.
>> 네. 저도 말씀을 아침 모닝브리프
1부 때 언제 드린 거 같은데 저도
회사 필요해서 컴퓨터 본체 사고
가격이 너무 올라서 깜짝 놀랐습니다.
메모리 가격 때문에 그렇게 된 거
같은데
>> 전부 다이 칩 인플레이션이라고 하는
그런 것들이
>> 모든 기업들의 음으로 양으로 영향을
미치고 있는 거 같습니다.
>> 알겠습니다. 이렇게 어 중요한
이슈들이 있어서 며칠 상관으로 다시
또 입심 정리 업데이트 해
주셨습니다.
>> 미국으로 넘어가 보겠습니다. 지난주
금요일 미국 시장 어떻게 됐는지
유리프로와 함께 알아보겠습니다.
>> 20 [목을 가다듬음] 26일 끝난
금요일 미국장 말씀드리도록
하겠습니다. 먼저 전반적으로 지수부터
보시면은 좌체적으로는 거의 보합
수준이었고요. SMP 500 -
0.505% 나스닥은 0.24%
다운은 그보다 좀 덜 빠진 0.09%
0% 하락으로 마무리했습니다. 다만
지수 자체보다는 좀 업종 내부 흐름이
좀 더 중요한 하루였는데요. 이제
금리랑 유가 자체는 좀 내려오긴
했는데 주식 시장 내부에서는 제가
아래쪽에 기재했는데 소파 금리랑
IRB 스프레드가 한 1b
-1bp까지 좁혀지면서 단기 자금
조달 여건이 좀 타이트해졌고 메모리
GTF라든지 뭐 마진 계좌 해치펀드
차입 수요 증가로 주식 파이낸신
비용이 좀 올라가면서 그동안 좀
과열됐었던 AI랑 좀 반도체
포지션에서 차익 실현이 좀 나오면서
솔님이 일부 좀 풀린 장이었다라고 볼
수 있을 것 같습니다. 하나씩 짚어
드리면서 텍스트 뭐 있는지 짚어
드리려고 하나씩 갖고 왔는데 먼저
유가 수준부터 보시면은 우측의 그림
보시면 금요일 장 이후 주말 그리고
오늘 중까지 해서 좀 가져왔는데요.
WTI 같은 경우에는 배럴당 70달러
수준이었고 브랜드는 72달러
수준이었습니다. 이제 금요일
장중에서는 72달러대에서 사실
69달러 대까지 좀 내려오는 흐름
보여줬다가 주말 동안에 다시 이제
70달러대로 올라왔습니다. 주말
사이에 중동 관련된 좀 긴장이 다시
좀 부각이 되면서 선물 시장에서
유가가 좀 튀는 움직임이 있긴
했었는데 장 마감한 이후에 그 미국에
이란이 계속 추가 충돌를 자재하고
대화 채널을 유지하겠다라는 보도가
악시스라는 매체를 통해서 좀 나오긴
했었습니다. 그래서 다시 안정된
흐름세를 보여 주긴 했는데이 매체에
따르면 이제 뭐 미국 고의 단국자를
인용하면서 뭐 미국과 이란이 걸프
지역에서 상호 보호 공격을
중단하겠다로 이렇게 합의했다라고
알려졌다라고 합니다. 그리고 이제
지난주에 뭐 수위소 회담에서 양측이
뭐 미국과 혁명 수비된 간을 뭐
한라인 구축에 합의했다라고는 이제
보도가 되긴 했었는데 좀 관련된
보도들이 엇갈리고 있더라고요.
그런
점에서가지
않고 확 오르지도 않고 이런
오르내림을 반복하는 보이고 그래서
이제 호르무즈 해 불확실성이 좀
완전히 아직까지 사라진게 아니기
때문에 유가 리스크 프리미엄 자체
낮세긴 했지만 여전히 좀 꼬리쪽
위험은 남아 있어서 최종적인 방향성은
트럼프의 이제 발언을 확인해야 된다
또 말씀드릴 수 있을 것 같습니다.
이제 금리 쪽도 보시면은 표면적으로
좀 안정적이긴 했습니다. 10년물
4.37% 37% 수준까지
내려왔고요. 유가도 이제 내려오면서
매크로만 보면은 위험 자산의 좀
우호적인 주식 시장에 좀 우호적인
환경처럼 보여지긴 했습니다. 네.
그런데 이제 좀 이런 아까
말씀드렸듯이 소파금리랑 IORB
말씀드리면서 수급 자체가 좀
파이트해졌기 때문에 이런 부분에
있어서 좀 주식 시장에서 좀 과열됐던
쪽에 위험도가 좀 많이 높아지지
않았나 정도로 다시금 한번 짚어 볼
수 있을 것 같습니다. 그래서 이런
흐름이랑 연결해서 반도체 쪽에
보시면은 반도체가 약했습니다. 자,
반도체 기업들 모아놓 ETF인
SMH가 있는데 제가 텍스트에 기재
드렸거든요. 요거는 4.3% 3%
가량 하락을 했고 이제 데이터 센터
네트워킹 쪽에 종 그 제품들 군을
갖고 있는 크레도 테크놀로지도
10.7% 가량 하락했습니다. 이제
비슷한 흐름 속에서 메모리랑
장비주들도 좀 약했는데요. 마이크론
같은 경우에는 뭐 6 한 7% 정도
어플라이드 메테리어스 6.2%
민선치도 비슷한 정도 그리고
샌디스크는 10.5% 5% 가량
하락을 했습니다. 반면 제가 지난주
계속 말씀드리고 있었던 흐름이
반도체랑 빅테크가 좀 반대 방향으로
움직이고 있다라고 말씀드렸던 거
같은데 빅테크 쪽은 반면으로 좀 일부
반등을 했습니다. 최근 좀
말씀드렸듯이 뭐 나타나고 있는 이런
메모리 반도체 약세 벌써 이제 빅테크
상대 강세 이런 흐름과 연결해서 볼
필요 있을 것 같고 메모리 가격 상승
이슈가 계속 나오고 있는데 이런
이슈가 뭐 그 수급을 받아가는 입장이
반도체 업제 자체는 좀 호재이긴
하지만 애플과 같은 이제 빅테크
입장에서는 비용 부담이 계속
원인일인일 것 같고요. 그런데 애플이
이제 올랐던 것을 좀 살펴보면은
금요일장에서는 오히려 이런 비용
자체에 대한 부담보다는 애플이 이런
공급망을 좀 선두적으로 확보하고
있다라는 점이 반도체 쪽에서는 좀
부정적으로 커졌던 센티먼트랑 다르게
좀 긍정적으로 해석되지 않았나 이런
것으로 좀 보입니다. 그래서 이렇게
비용이 계속 올라가는 환경에서도
마진을 이제 방어할 수 있는
기업이라는 점이 좀 더 받아들여진게
주식상 그 주가 가치 상승에 좀
비여하지 않았나 정도로 좀 해석을 해
볼 수 있을 것 같습니다. 그리고 또
개별 반도체 쪽에서는 제가 하단
텍스트의 온 세미컨터를 언급을 해
드렸는데요. 이제 좀 많이 빠진
종목들을 보다 보니까 이제이 종목이
가장 먼저 눈에 들어왔는데 24%
가량 좀 급락을 했습니다. 금요일에
좀 시네틱스라는 회사 인수권이
있었는데이 시네틱스라는 회사를 70억
달러 규모의 전량 주식 교환과 뭐
방식으로 인수한다라는 보도가
있었습니다. 데 다만이 하락 추세가
너무 이제 수치적으로만 보면 크긴
한데 또 부장님 항상 말씀하시
대비해서 얼마나 인수건이 컸는지를
봐야 된다라고 하면이 시총 대비 인수
규모를 좀 보면 타당하다 정도로 좀
볼 수 있을 것 같은데 중요한 거는이
온 세미컨덕터 입장에서 현금
유출보다는이 주식 발행에 따른 희석
효과 때문나 정도로 보여지고 만약에
시가총액 대비 한 70억 달러 규모의
주식을 새로 발행하는 구조다라고
하면은 한 20% 안팎에 이제 시석을
반영할 수가 있거든요.
자체가
인수에 따른 좀 복잡성 정도의 할인이
같이 반영된 움직임으로 볼 수 있지
않을까로 볼 수 있을 것 같습니다.
반도체랑 또 다른 반대급으로 이동하고
있는게 헬스케어도 주목이 되는데
헬스케어 같은 경우가 좀 강했습니다.
좀 제가 왔다 갔다 하는데요. SMP
이제 헬스케어 섹터 보시면 다른
종목과 좀 다르게 3.16%가량 6%
가량 뚜렷하게 상승을 했고 섹터의 좀
상승 종목 비율도 제가 아침에 블룸
보고 체크했는데 한 88% 가량으로
좀 많이 올랐습니다. 이게 아무래도
모더나 같은 일부 바이오 좀 대형
바이오만 올라왔다기보다는 대형
제약이나 바이오 전반이 좀 같이 오
장이었는데요. 바이오 쪽에서 뭐
아무래도 승인이 중요한 관건이다
보니까 뭐 그 FDA 승인
시즌인가라고 생각을 처음엔 했었는데
뭐 승인 시즌이다라기보다는 시총이 큰
기업들의 좀 개별 이슈가 함께 움직인
장이었던 것으로 보입니다. 밀라
릴리가 7% 가량 올랐고 존슨 존슨이
4% 뭐 에비브가 4.2% 가량
올랐는데 이제 에비브 같은 경우가 좀
강 가장 강력하게 개별적인 이슈가
있었습니다. 여기서 이제 낸 특성
이제 약이 있는데이 6세 이상 소화
뭐 관절염 치료제로 FDA 승인을
받았다고 하더라고요. 그래서 이런 좀
긍정적인 이슈가 나오면서 좀
전반적으로 바이오섹터 인수합병권도
있었고 그러면서 확 끌어올린 것으로
보입니다. 그래서 이런 개별 뉴스가
좀 있었고 반도체 AI에서 좀 빠진
자금이 대형 제약이나 바이오 쪽으로
이동한 로테이션 장이었다라고도
짚어드릴 수 있을 것 같습니다.
>> 추가적으로 우측 하단에 보시면 자동차
쪽에 루시드가 15.6% 6%가량
급등을 했습니다. 이게 우버랑 뉴로랑
로봇 택시 협력 기대가 이미 있긴
있었거든요. 근데 이미이 기대감이 한
차례를 반영된 이후에 좀 정 그
안에는 전기차 수요 둔화랑 자금 소진
리스크가 부각이 되면서 주가가 좀
눌린 측면이 있긴 있었는데 지난주
금요일에 좀 구조 조정 발표가
있었습니다. 그러면서 비용 절관
기대가 좀 부각하게 되면서 반등이
나오지 않았나 정도로 좀 이슈 짚어
볼 수 있을 것 같고 이제 다만 인력
감축 뉴스는 좀 장기 성장
신호라기보다는 방어적인 측면으로
해석이 가능하잖아요. 이제 그렇기
때문에 뭔가 터너라운드가
확정됐다라기보다는 비용 절감 기대랑
쇼커버가 좀 겹친 반등이다라고 볼 수
있을 것 같습니다. 오늘 좀 이것저것
많이 말씀을 드렸는데 좀 정리를 해
보자면 금요일 장은 좀 지수 자체는
보합이었지만 내부적으로는 좀 큰
변화가 있었다.
가는 내려고 미국이란 공격중보도
나오면서 표면적인 매크로 환경 자체는
우호적이었습니다. 하지만 이제 뭐
소파 금리랑 IRB 스프랜드가 좀
많이 좁혀졌고 주식 파이낸싱 비용
상승이 부각되면서 시장 내부 수급은
좀 타이트해졌다. 그래서 그 결과로
좀 과열됐었던 AI랑 반도체에서는
차익 실현이 나왔고 반대로 헬스케어랑
일부 이제 종목적으로 좀 자금 이동한
장이었습니다.
이번 주 금요일 미국장이 좀 독립
기념일 대체 휴장입니다.
미국의 마지막 거래 목요일 밤에 미국
고용지표 발표가 되거든요. 그래서이
고용 지표와 금리 방향을 다시 결정할
수도 있고이 결과가 저 금요일
한국장에 바로 반영될 수 있는
구조라서 오늘 계장 이후에는 미국
반도체 차익 실현이 얼마나
진정되는지가 관건일 것으로 보이고
설령 약세가 있다 하더라도 이제 미국
반도체 약세를 그 기업 자체의
펀더멘탈 그리고 이제 이거를 국내
반도체 펀더멘탈이랑 수급이 얼마나 잘
흡수할 수 있을 것이냐가 앞으로이
랠리의 지속성을 좀 볼 수 어 판단할
수 있는 변수일 것으로 보입니다.
이상입니다.음
>> 감사합니다. 그럼 이번 주 고용
지표는 미국 시장의 목요일 미국
시장에는 반영이 되나요? 아니면
>> 어 미국 시장 미국 시간 기준으로
목요일 마치고 고용 지표가 나오기
때문에
>> 미국 시장 정규장애는 반영이 안
됐나요? 금요일 휴장이니까. 어,
정규장이 반영이 안 되는 것으로 알고
있습니다.
>> 음. 그러면 미국 시장 선물이나 뭐
이런 것들을 보고 한국 시장에는
선반영하겠으나 미국은 다음 월요일 날
>> 반영을 하게 될 것 같습니다.
그러네요. 말씀 쭉 들어 보니까
그동안 너무 핫했던 종목들은 쭉 많이
빠진 거 같은데 뭐 애플도 다시
반등하고 마이크로소프트 줄줄줄줄
흘러내리던 것도 6% 가까이 오르고
팔란티어 엠로빈 같은 소프트웨어
기업들도 반등이 나오고 이렇게 좀
시장이 주도주는 분명히 있더라도
그렇지 않은 종목들도 펀더멘탈이
지나치게 반영이 안 되는 주가까지
내려가 있다면 좀 반등이 있어야
되는데 뭐 그런 측면으로 이해를 하고
싶습니다. 조정이라기보단
이렇게 마무리하도록 하겠습니다. 미국
시장까지 봤고요. 어 지난 주말
포함해서 가상자산 시장 어떻게 됐는지
주역 주임과 함께 보겠습니다. 네.
장시 말씀드리겠습니다. 72시간가
흐름 먼저 보시면 어 [콧방귀]
이란과 공격 이란과 그 미국의 공격이
중단했음에도 불구하고 그러면 크게
반응 없는 모습 보실 수 있을 것
같습니다. 그래서 어이 지금 가격
흐름이 특별하게 호재에 반응하지
못하고 악재에는 더 강하게 반응하는
그런 모습을 보여준 장세가 지속되고
있다. 이렇게 보시면 될 거 같고요.
어 지난주 금요일 날 변동성이 좀
강했는데 그 지난주 금요일 날부터
이제 공격이 시작되다 보니까 어
미국이 이란을 때리는 그런 시작 그런
모습들에 좀 악제가 식하게 반영되는
모습을 보여줬었고요. 실제로 오늘
새벽에 이제 어 미국과 이란이 공격
그만하겠다라는 것들이 나왔는데
그거에 대해 크게 반응이 없는 것을
봤을 때 이게 시장 자체도이 미국과
트럼프와 그 이란의 그 스탠스를 믿지
않는 부분이 있지 않나 하는 생각을
하고 있습니다. 그거는 어 유가를
보면서 강하게 생각을 했는데요.
오른쪽에 보시면 유가는 이게 주말간
차트입니다. 주말간 차트 봤을 때
아까 유리프럽게 설명해 주셨지만 거의
변화가 없고 크게 쇼크의 움직임이
전혀 없었습니다. 그렇기 때문에 어
이제 시장이 어이 미국과 이란이
장기화됐다는 장기화 될 거라는 것은
어느 정도 배팅을 하고 있다라고
개인적으로 생각을 하고 장기가 되면서
그 더
>> 격화가 되지 않는다라는 거는 충분히
관리를 하면서 간다라고 생각을 하고
있습니다. 그래서 이번에도 주말
사이에 어 공격이 나왔고요. 어 또
굳이굳ు굳이 보도를 해 가지고 원래는
더 일찍 발표하려고 그랬었는데 주말로
밀었다. 어 이런 식의 보도도
나오더라고요. 그래서 이런 걸 봤을
때 어 쉽게 끝날 것 같지 않다.
그리고 인정 인정을 저희가 다 해야
될 거 같고 어 모든 투자들이 심지어
인정을 하고 있다. 인정을 하면서
그런 것들 투자에 반영이 되고
있다라는 것을 저희가 인지하고 하면
될 것 같습니다. 그 피디엔 보시면
어 익스트림 피어 구간에 18 정도를
아직도 기록하고 있고요. 현물 ETF
순위 순위치 보시면 어 장 그 금
목요일 금요일만 해서 1.14년
정도가 유출이 되었고 어 지난 한 주
동안 봤을 땐 1.79빌년 정도
유출이 됐으니까 어 지난 한 주도
유출세가 좀 큰 어 한 주였다라
보시면 될 것 같습니다.이 출세가
조금 완화되는 분위기는 조금 2 3
한 2주간 지난 2주간 보여줬었는데
지난 한 주간은 다시 한번 큰
유출세가 나오게 된다라는 것을
확인하실 수가 있을 것 같고요. 어
왼쪽 밑에 있는 것은 크립토 애시스
그
컨센서스입니다. 그래서 뭐 어떤
사람이 약세를 보고 있나? 그러니까이
많이 포스트에 올려서 내가 어
비트코인이나이 크립토의 가격이 어떻게
될 것 같다라는 건 전망해 준
애널리스트다라고 보시면 될 거
같은데이 정확순으로 1등부터
10등까지 나와 있는 수 어
차트입니다. 그래서 어 지금 위에서
아래까지 보시면 강세를 보는
강세론자들이 세 명밖에 없고요. 그
강세의 정도도 어 굉장히 많이
내려왔다라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
그래서 제가 지난번에 한번 어 한
3월 3월쯤에 말씀을 드릴 때는이
컨센서스가 거의 강세 반, 약세 반
정도였던 것을 제가 확인할 수 있을
것 같 같은데 그때 당시 가격을 보면
굉장히 좋았었습니다. 그래서 그런
부분들이 지금 현재 반영이 되고 있는
거 아닌가?이 이러시들도 계속해서
가격 흐름을 보면서 전망을 바꾸고
새로운 전망을 내주기 때문에 이런
부분들이 충분히 가격에 영향을 받는
분석글이 나오지 않을까는 생각은
개인적으로 저희가 인지를하면서 가야
될 거 같고 그럼에도 불구하고 지금
약세를 보는 사람들이 강한계 약세를
보고 있으면서 그 약세를 보는 비율이
한 70% 이상 된다. 상위 열모로
봐서 70% 이상 된다 이렇게 보시면
될 거 같습니다. 이제 오른쪽에 현재
상황이 지속되는 것일까라고 적어
놨는데이 블룸버그의 주말 사이사에
나온 차트가 있어서 한번
가져봤습니다. 어, 밑에 있는게 그
반도체 쪽 어, ETF 수급이다라고
보시면 될 거 같고요. 그리고 위에
있는게 어, 금이나 비트코인 ETF에
있던 유출세이라고 보시면 될 것
같습니다.이 차트가 위로가 아니라
아래로 내려가고 있으니까 유출세다라고
보시면 될 거 같은데 결국이 모든
수급이 거의 비트코인 아, 그 반도체
쪽으로 빨려 들어가고 있다. 정확히
[목을 가다듬음] 그렇게 보시면 될
거 같습니다. 정확하게 역상관계를
보이고 있는 것을 제가 올해로만 봤을
땐 확인할 수가 있을 것 같습니다.
그래서 금쪽도 그렇고 지금 기금 속도
가격이 좋다라고 보기는 어렵기 때문에
어 그런 부분들이 지금 충분히
반영되고 있는게 아닌가? 어쨌든데
귀금속은 지금 달러 인덱스 영향을
많이 받는 것도 있다라고 보고
있습니다. 어 주요 시에는 제가
간단하게 차트만 두 개 가져와서 이걸
설명을 드리면 될 것 같습니다. 어이
제목에 this time is
different 이렇게 써
놨는데요.이 강세로 이제 비트코인이든
어 뭐 주식이든 어 굉장히 많이
조정폭을 보이고 있는 자산에 대해서
비율를 던질 때 어 이번엔 다르다라고
하는 사람들의 약간음
풍자하는 말이다라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 어 그래서 이번에 비트코인
44년 실현 가격 리스크 대비 보상
비율이 크립토 컨트에 있는 자료가
하나 있는데요. 4년마다 어이
바차트가 파란색 있는 바차트가 갑자기
급격하게 올라가는 것을 확인하실 수가
있을 것 같습니다.이 바차트가 올라
급격하게 스파이크가 나오는 부분은 어
내가 지금 들어간 리스크 대비의 보상
비율이 가장 높았었다를 나타내는 어
바차트 자료인데요. 어 결국 이때가
저점이었다는 것을 확인하실 수가 있을
것 같습니다. 이때가 이때 샀으면
가장 보상 비율이 높았다. 이런 걸
저희가 확인할 수 있을 것 같은데
사실 이거를 맞추려고이 자료를 가져온
건 아니고요. 아직도 조금 남았다.
아직도 실험 가격, 그러니까 사람들의
평균 단가에 도달하기까지 한 시간이
남았기 때문에 52,000불 해서
48,불 정도까지 구간이 될 수 있을
것 같고요. 그 구간에 비상 보상
비율이 왔을 때 갑 갑자기이 차트가
뛰면서 저점을 좀 확인하고 어 보상의
비율이 조금 높아지는 그런 흐름을
저희가 확인할 수가 있을 것 같고요.
오른쪽에 있는 차트를 보시면 장기
홀더의 손실 비중이 얼타임하를
기록하고 있습니다. 그래서 오랫동안
들고 있는 사람들 이거 제가 2년에서
어 그 이상 정도를 하는 사람들을
장기홀더다라고 할 거 같은데요.
실제로 그 사람이 가지고 있는지 안
가지고 있는지 판단한다기보다는 어떤
한 주소에서 2년 이상 머물면 아이
사람 장기 홀더구나 이렇게 그냥
취급한다 이렇게 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 그래서 그 홀더의 비율이
봤을 때 어 지금 역대 최대라고
보시면 될 거 같은데요. 어, 이게
뭔가 조정폭이 계속 역대의 최대로
길어져서 그렇다라고 보기다보다는 어,
뭔가이 강에 이번에 있었던 사이클이
사람들의 기대와 다르게 금방
끝났다라고 보는게 또 맞을 것
같습니다. 그래서 사람들이 이번에
원래 사이클이 한 번에 길게 가고
그다음에 잠깐 내려왔다가 약간
더블탑에 더블탑의 약간 모습을
보여주는 어 그런 비트코인 차트를
항상 보여줬었는데 이번에는 그런
사람들의 기대와 다르게 어 조금 어
뒤늦게 진입한 사람들은 손실의 구간이
있을 확률이 굉장히 높고 아까
말씀드린 것처럼 실현 가격이라고 하는
거는 사람들의 평균 단가입니다.
그러니까 그 사람들의 평균 단가를
기어이 터치하고 나서 절반에 이상
절반 이상의 사람들이 손실 구간에
들어가고 나서야 바닥을 잡는다라는
뜻이니까 그런 구간에 어 돌입을 하게
됐을 때 어 그다음 비 가격을 잡 그
바닥을 잡을 수 있다라는 흐름을
보시면 될 거 같고 실제로 지금 단기
홀더들이 손실을 많이 보고 있다
보니까 어 그런 부분들이 사람들이
쉽절하지 못하고 있는 상황입니다.
근데 정말 자기 평균 단가보다 어 훅
내려오게 된다라고 하면 그제서의
손절이 좀 나오면서 비트공 자체의
가격이 좀 가벼워질 수 있고 그제서
좀 터널한 수 있는 그름을 좀 기대할
수 있지 않을까 하는 차원에서 두
가지 차트를 가져왔습니다.
이상입니다. 오늘 설명해 주신 주요
이슈에 두 가지 차트를 보여 주셨는데
어 물론가 봐야 알겠습니다만 저희가
농담처럼 [목을 가다듬음]
뭐 약속의 9월 10월 이렇게
말씀드리고 있는데
>> 어이 차트들도 그 저희의 전망을 좀
지지하는 지지한다라고 볼 수도
있을까요?
>> 네. 네.
적극적으로 지지한다고 보면 될 거
같고요. 사실 그거를 정확하게 48
포인트 아 48,000불 그리고
52불이 온다라고 보면 저희가 또
틀릴 수가 있지만 보수적으로
보수적으로 투자하시는 분들이나
보수적으로이 비트코인을 보시는 분들이
주식 투자는 더 많을 것 같으니까
그런 차원에서는이 52,000 불을
찍는 걸 확인하고 가는게 오히려
맞다라고 보고 있고요. 그냥 그때
갔을 때 항상 바닥 비율에서 보상의
비율이 컸었다. 그냥 이런 차원에서
말씀드렸습니다.
>> 알겠습니다. 저희가 코인 가격,
가상화폐 이런 것들 좀 밸루에이션이
상당히 어려워서 시장 이동성이나 투자
심리 이런 것들 체크를 위해서 같이
보고 있는데요. 어 아직까지는 뭐
그렇게 투자 심리가 활발하게
되살아나거나 뭐 시장의 유동성
비트코인으로 [목을 가다듬음]
넘어가서 유동성 장세다라고
얘기하기에는 단초가 안 보이는 거
같습니다. 시간이 좀 더 지나서 물로
익어야 되지 않나 싶은데 계속
채슬리에서 확인해 드릴 거니까 1부
함께 계속 함께 해 주시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 오늘 1부가 살짝 일찍
끝날 것 같은데요. 월요일이라 2부에
밸루에이션도 봐야 되고 내용이 좀
듭니다. 1부 마치도록 하고 2부
시작할 때도 함께 해 주시길 바라면서
함께 해 주신 채밀턴 여러분
감사드립니다. 다
[음악]
เฮ
>> [음악]
[음악]
>> 안녕하세요. 행복한 투자의 여행을
체슬리 투자 전문과 함께 채슬리 모닝
브리프 오늘 6월 29일 월요일 2부
순서 시작하도록 하겠습니다.
행복한 주말 보내셨습니까? 아 주말
별주부 전 잘 시청하셨다고
>> 예 거저께는 세 시간만 너무 많이
했는데 저희가 하면서도 순삭 지나가는
느낌이라서 아주 저도 재밌게
진행을 했었는데 유리프로가 특히
고생을 많이 해 주셨던 거 같습니다.
그리고 어 타벤더 님 질문 등등 해서
참
별조부전 진행하면서 참 진짜 별난
사람들이다 이렇게
주식을 좋아하면서 본업도 있는데 와
가지고 발표를 해 주시고 저한테도 참
많은 도움이 됐었는데 아마 시청하신
분들은
한 주간 정리하고 또 한 주간 시장을
어 전망을 해 보는데 도움이 되셨을
거라 생각합니다. 니다. 자,
최무사장님 자료는 어떤 자료
가져오셨습니까?
>> 예. 어 일단 금요일 날 반도체 쪽이
또 급락이 나왔습니다. 목요일 날
아이콘 테크날로지 실적 발표한
다음에또 급등이 나서기도 했고요.
이렇게 좀 급등락이
오가는 가운데서 업종별로 보면은 오른
업종들도 꽤 있었거든요. 그래서 어
현재 오늘하고 내일하고 해서 어
상반기가
2거래일 남았고요. 그리고
현 좀 솔림이 심한 상황에서 아침에
유리프로가 얘기했던 것처럼 리밸런싱
그 솔림의화 레버리지 청산 이런
부분들이 어 다 맞물려 있지 않은가
싶습니다. 아 특별히 종목 개 어 개
개 개 개 개별적인 종목별로 뭐
특별한 이슈가 있었던 건 아닌 거
같고요. 그래서 장시장 전 시장
전반적인
어떤 현재 위치를 보면은 어 피엔
그레이드 인덱스가 아 지금 피어 영역
그 더군다나 이제 극단적 공포 영역에
유지가 되고 있고요. 이게 며칠째
계속 이어지고 있는데 옆에 그 SMP
500이랑 비교를 해 보면은 SMP
500이 빨간선인데 어 신고가를내는
과정에서도 B앤 그리드가
어 공포 영역적으로 어 계속 가는
모습이 관찰되고 있는데 아 이거는
일부 어 섹터들에 의한 솔림 때문에
기한 걸로 어 보이고 있습니다. 기한
걸로 보이고 있습니다.이 이 뛰어인
그레이드 인덱스가 아 실제로 어 상승
종목서와 하락 종목서를 비교하거나
또 신고가나 신적가 이런 종목들을
비교하다 보니까 그런 것들이
극단적으로 갈 때음
삐어 구간으로 어 진입하는 경향이
있기 때문에 지금도 어 IT 일부
AI 인프라나 AI 반도체 쪽으로 어
계속해서 솔림이 일어나다 보니까 어
피어 영역에 어 진입해 되는 것으로
판단이 되고요. 그래서 어 결론적으로
그 금요일 하루만 보면은 반도체
솔림이나 과열을 시키는 과정 그리고
차익 실현, 레버리지 청산, 리밸런싱
요런 부분들이 좀 어 계절적으로
맞물리면서 어 나오지 않았나 오고
있는데 필반 지수 보시면은 어 대체로
1일 수익률이 어 전부 다 어 적게는
뭐 한 자릿수 초중반 많게는 두 자릿
수까지 이렇게 빠졌는데
일부 어 20% 이상 빠진
온세미컨덕터 같은 경우는 어 주식
발행을 한 20% 정도 해서
인수한다는 이슈가 있었기 때문에 희석
가만하면은 20% 이상 빠지는 거는
뭐 그렇게 특별한 일이 아니었고요.
특성별로 보면은 올해 200%에서
700% 상승한 메모리 저장 장치.
그리고 마이크 즉 이제 마이크로
테크로지 샌디스크나 웨스턴 디지털나
시게이트 이런 종목들이 6에서 한
10% 어 이상 하락을 했고요.
그리고 온세미는 좀 전에 말씀드렸던
대로 인수권에 의해서 20% 낙폭을
기록했고 어 옆에 SP 500의 섹터
성과를 보면은 연초 이후에 상대적으로
소외됐던 건강 관리나 자유소비제나
부동산 필수 소비제 어 요런 그 IT
인프라 또는 반도체의 반대편에 있는
어 구경제 주식들이 그리고 또
소회되였던 주식들이 반등하는 그런
모습들 들이 관찰됐습니다.
그래서 이거는 펀더멘탈
요인이라기보다도 그냥 수급 요인,
심리 요인 이거로 보는게 맞다고
생각을 하고 있고 최근 5일간
동일가중 지수를 추종하는 RSP 같은
경우도 좀 섹터나 종목들이 확산된
모습들이 관찰되면서 어 시총
어 지수를 추종하는 SPY 대비해서
어 상대 성파가 가 한 4% 정도 어
좋았던 걸로 어 나오면서 이거 역시
어 섹터나 종목의 확산 솔림의 완화
리밸런싱 요런 부분들을 설명하는 것이
아닐까 싶습니다. 반면에 그 건강
관리 지수를 추정하는 XLV나 엑셀류
유틸리티를 추정하는 XLU 그리고
IT를 추정하는 XLK 그러니깐 어
두 그 건강 권리나 유틸리티
소외되었던 업종에서 최근에 어 반등이
좀 세게 나오고 있고 상대적으로 IT
쪽은
어 마이너스를 기록하면서 어 양
섹터가음
상대 성과 국가가 차별되는 모습들이
단기적으로 어 나오고 있다고 보시면
될 것 같습니다.
그래서 지금 현재 어 마이크론하고 어
필반 지수 EPS 밸루에이션 가져는데
특히 이걸 가져온 이유는 어 마이콘
테크놀로지가 지난 목요일 날 굉장히
서프라이즈한 실적을 발표했는데이
부분이 필반 지수에 얼마나 영향을
줬고 어 마이크론 자체적으로는 EPS
상향 조정이 얼마나 이루어졌고
밸류에이션은 어느 정도 되는지 좀
대표적인 어 반도체 어 섹터 내
종목이기 때문에 가져왔는 는데 일단은
전체적으로 필반 지수는 주간
기준으로는 7.9%가 하락을
했습니다. 그런데 PR 자체는
27.8배에서 24.8배. 물론 이제
주가가 하락을 해서 어 PR이 낮아진
상황도 있겠지만 아가 3.3% 어
상향 조정
되면서 어
그
주가 EPS 상향 조정거 된 거 대비
주가 하락폭은 어 컸다라고
어 보시면 될 거 같고요. 어
그러면서 PER도 좀 낮아졌다라고
보시면 될 것 같습니다. 어, 마이콘
테크날로지 보시면 아, PR 같은
경우 음, 필 필반 지수 같은 경우는
전고점이 한 29.1배까지
올라갔었는데
최근에 주가 하락 그리고 EPS 상향
조정에 의해서 24.85배 어,
25배를 좀 살짝 깨고 어, 내려온
상황이고요. 밸루에이션 부담이 그만큼
좀 어, 줄어들었다라고 보시면 될 것
같고. 네. 그 이유는 어, 최근에
마이크론의 실적이 음.
그 발표되면서 필반 지수의 EPS
상향 조정에도 상당히 기여한 것으로
보이고요. 마이콘 테크놀로지에
상당히 등락이 있었는데
일주일간
낙폭은 한 0.1% 정도 되고요.
PER은 전에 일주일 전에 한
10.8배에서 8.2배까지 내려왔는데
아 그 이유는 주가가 빠진 것이
아니라 EPS가 32.4% 4% 한
주간 어 상향 조정되면서 어
계단식으로 상향 조정되면서 PR이 더
낮아지는 효과가 있었습니다. 그래서
전반적으로 마이크론 테크놀로지 EPS
상향 주에 따라서 필반 지수 EPS
그 상향이 있었고요. 어 그리고 주가
하락이 동반되면서 어 피 멀티플이
필반 지수하고 어 바이콘 테크놀로지
마이콘 테크놀로지는 뭐 미미하지만
있었다고 보시면 될 것 같습니다.
그래서 일부 IB들 그러니까 JP건
같은데 그 IB들 쪽에서는 그
전반적으로 탑다운 전략 자체를 아 일
그 솔림 완화 과정에서 어 주 섹터
조정 가능성이 있기 때문에 단기적으로
어 변동성을 축소하기 위한 바벨
전략을 제시하기도 했는데이 바벨
전략은 이렇게 변동성이 커질 때마다
그 뭐 뱅크업 아메리카나 뭐 이런 큰
아비 비들 쪽에서 어 나오는 전략이긴
한데 어 물론 그 변동성을 좀 줄이기
위한 어떤 수단이긴 하지만 주도
섹터가 세게 그 추세를 가지고 올라갈
때는 오히려 그 주도 섹터의 상승이
어 섹터의 그 하락에 의해서 상세되는
효과가 있기 때문에 어 실제로 저
같은 경우는 뭐 기계적으로 이렇게 뭐
바벨 전략을 을 하거나 그러지는
않는데 제가 보기에는 어 단기적으로
그 월말이나 분기말 이런 반기말
영향의 어떤 계절성
또는 쏠림 과열 완화 과정이 이어지고
있다고 생각을 하고 있고요. 그에
따라서 차익 실현, 뭐 레버리지
정산, 리밸런싱 어 이런 수순을 겪게
되면은 어 변동성이 조금 어 잦아질
수도 있지 않을 잦아질 수도 있지
않을까라고 생각을 하고 있고 삼성전자
실적 발표 얼마 전에 그 마이크론도
있었지만 어 잠정 실적 발표하고 어
비테크 실적 프리뷰어 어 요런
부분들이 분기점이 돼서 기존 주의
보건력이 강화되지 않을까 싶습니다.
그리고 한 정확히 날짜는 그
정해지지가 않았는데 이번에 7월이
7월 4일이 독립 기념일이라 원래
휴장인데 7월 4일이 토요일입니다.
그래서 7월 3일 날 그 대체 봉일로
지정을 해서 미국은 휴장이 되고요.
7월 2일마저도 어 반장밖에 안
열립니다. 어, 미국 시각으로 한
1시에 오후 1시에 어, 장이
마무리되기 때문에 이번에 이번 주
미국 시장은 어, 한 3일에다가 3일
반 정도 어, 열릴다고 어, 보시면
될 것 같습니다. 그래서 테슬라
실적이 아마도 그 실적이라기보다 그
판매대수 발표하는 거 분기마다
판매될수 발표하는 거가
이번 주에 1일이나 2일 어 그때쯤
나올 것 같은데
어 전체 전반적인 성장주에 중요한
바로미터 역할을 이전에는 했었는데
요즘은 좀 존재감이 어 줄어들긴
했지만 좀 어쨌든 M7에 속하는
종목이 하나로 로서 미리 좀
보면은요.
아, 2분기 판매대수 발표가
시장에서는 아,
판매대수를
39만6,000대 정도로 보고
있습니다. 지난 1분기에
35만8,대에서
한 4원대 정도 늘어난 숫자고요.
이거는 Y로 3.2%가
증가된 숫자입니다. 그리고 영업
이익률은 컨센서스 기준으로 2분기에
4.59%가 나올 걸로 예상이 되고
있고요. 이전에 나왔던 4.2
어 2%보다는 한 0.4% 포인트
개선될 걸로 보고 있습니다. 아
중요한게 보는게 이제 캐시 플로우인데
영업 현금 흐름 쪽에서 3.29빌리언
달러가 예상이 되고 있고요. 그리고
캐피랄 익스디처가 한 6.5빌 5년이
있었을 걸로 시장에서는 보고
있습니다. 그래서 이전
대비해서 상당히 좀 많은 그 케펙스가
쓰였다고 보시면 될 거 같고 그에
따라서 영업 현금흐름이 어 -3.8
빌리언 달러 이렇게 좀 어 추정이
되고 있습니다. 근데 그 이후에 어
보시면음
캐피탈 익스펜드죠. 그러니까 케펙스
쪽이 3분기에도 한 7.7빌리언
17빌리언 달러 정도로 예상되고
있어서 계속해서 어 테슬라는 이번
분기부터 해 가지고 케펙스가 계속 어
늘어나는 걸로 시장에서 보고 있기
때문에 프리캐시플로도
이전에 계속 양
플러스 숫자를 어 기록을 했어
했었고이 부분 때문에 재무적으로
상당히 건전한 것으로 어 평가가
됐었는데 어 케펙스가 계속해서 앞으로
분기별로 늘어날 걸로 예상이 되면서
영업 어 잉여의 헌금흐름에도 영향을
줄 걸로 시장에서는 좀 보고 있는 거
같습니다.
일단 나와 봐야 될 것 같고요.
판매될수
쪽에서
큰 변화가 없을 거 같고
일단은 그 실적 발표에서요
부분이 케픽스 부분이 어떻게 되느냐에
따라서 어 주가 모멘텀에도 좀 영향을
주지 않을까 싶습니다. 어 일단
주가하고 어 테슬라 P 보시면은 지금
주가는 YT드로 15.6% 6% 정도
하락이 돼 있고요. EPS는
그 2분기 보시면은 0.43달러로
Yi로 어 8.6% 정도 증가하는
걸로 돼 있습니다. 그리고 3분기에는
0.5엔 모는
향후 뭐 그 분기별로 볼 때 꾸준히
증가하는 걸로 시장에서는 어 추정을
하고 있습니다. 지금 PR 같은
경우는 176배 정도의 어 거래가
되고 있고요. 이전에 저점 같은
경우는 한 160배였습니다. 그래서
그 다른 빅테크들과 마찬가지로 어
케펙스에 대한 그 투자자들이 느끼는
어 민감도는 상당히 앞으로 조금 커질
수도 있지 않을까 이런 생각이
듭니다. 이상입니다.
>> 음. 실적 발표는 언제쯤에?
>> 자, 실적 발표는 아, 7월 한
20일 경에 하더라고요. 7월 20일
경예. 예.이 예. 정확한 날짜는
정해지진 않았습니다. 아직까지. 예.
지금 테슬라 주가 EPS 추위를
보니까
>> 예.
>> 흰색이 EPS 주인데
>> 어, 다른 최근에 뭐 반도체나 요쪽은
실적 발표할 때마다 이익 추정치가
위로 빵 뛰면서 우상향 EPS 추위를
보이는 반면에
>> 예. 테슬라는 한 번씩 그냥
폭포스처럼 한번 확 빠졌다가
올라오다가 확 빠졌다가 올라오는데
계속 저점을 낮춰가는 모습이 실적
발표할 때마다 약간 뭐 쇼크가 없었나
보네. 이게 실적 발표할 때마다 조금
사람들이 기대감을 가졌다가 진짜
실적을까 보니까 기대보다 못한 실적이
나오고 더군다나
그 중요한 거 이제 일론 머스크의
비전 제신인데 그런 비전에서 구체적인
숫자가 안 나오다 보니까 어 EPS가
다시 기대감으로 올랐다가 하향
조정되는 그런 패턴이 이어지고 있는
거 같습니다.
>> 그렇네요. 보.
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
그리고 여기도 나오지만
이번에
아까 잉 현금 흐름이 38억 달러
정도
마이너스인데
다음 분기도 뭐 별 볼래 없고 그죠?
>> 예.
>> 음.
그래서 말씀하신 대로 꿈은 많은데 어
숫자가 지금 계속 안 나오는 상황이고
그리고 캐팩터가 이제 증가하는 부분이
>> 예요
>> 부분이 청원의 팀쿡도 그렇고
앨런머스크도 그렇고 다이 메모리
메모리 가격 반등에 반등이 아니라 뭐
급등에 폭등에네
>> 다들 짜증을 내면서 지금 이런저런
얘기를 하고 있는데이
>> 케팩스 자체가 Q가 뭐 두 배
늘어났다라기보다는
>> 예
>> 어이 메모리 가격이 급등하다 보니까
>> 어쩔 수 없이 비용 이만큼
>> 늘어난 거 아닌가
>> 그렇습니다. 예 그 부분이 상당 부분
기여할 겁니다. 예.
어 그래서 지금은 뭔가를 계속 투자를
해야 되는 기업 입장에서 특히나
메모리를 갖다 써야 되는 기업들
입장에서는
이익이 또 이번에 실적 발표할 때도
또 별 볼 일 없이 쇼커가 나올
가능성이 좀 높겠다. 이런 생각이
드네요.
>> 예. 음. 반면에 이번에 테슬라 모델
X 자율주행을 또 제가 경험을 해
봤잖아요.
>> 예.
>> 어, 그 경험하고 나서는 오늘도
아침에 출근하는데 앞에 모델 X가
진행하는데
>> 어, 이제는 달리 보여.
>> 뭐
>> 차가 달리 보이고 그 자율주행이
부연을 하는게 와,이 정도 벌써이
정도 수준이구나.
그래서 실제 서비스 자체의
자율주행이라든지 나중에 또 우리 삶에
침투할 휴먼의 로봇 이런 걸 생각해
보면 그 먼 미래가
오히려 더 어 구체적이고
좀 믿음이 가능
그 믿음으로 이제 주가가 움직이는 거
같아요. 예. 저는 그 분기점을
어때로 좀 그냥 그 내피시인데
생각하고 있냐면
>> 어 [목을 가다듬음] 지금 로봇시가
다니고 있잖아요. 여전히 옆에 보조
운전자가 있습니다. 보조 운전자가
>> 없어지는 날
>> 어 그 날이 이제
>> 비로소 완전한 자율주행이 실현되는 어
시점이 아닌가 싶습니다. 그러면서
실제로 우리가 뭐 여기서도 집에 있는
차를 그냥 원격으로 조정해서 여기 그
뭐 우리 건물 앞에 갖다 놓다든가
아니면 그걸 통해서 상업적으로 놀고
있는 차를 이용을 해서 우버처럼
활용한다든가
어 그런 시점에 엄청난 그 주가에
폭발력이 있지 않을까 어 그런
생각인데 그런 부분들에 대해서 조금
조금씩 이제 어 지연되거나 조금
조금씩 그 미진 모멘텀이 좀 어
약하거나 이러기 때문에 아직까지
주가가 조금 기고 있는 거 아닌가
싶습니다.
>> 네
>> 그 테슬라 오느분이 그러시더라고요.
아, 술 먹고 나서 대리 운전 부를
때 제일 아깝다고 하면서
>> 실제 대리 기사분이 오셔 가지고도
그냥 자율주행해 놓으면지가 알아서
가는
>> 그런데 반드시 운전자가 있어야 되다
보니까
>> 예
>> 그래서 대리 기사분을 부르기는 하는데
아 되게 돈이 아깝다 할 정도로
기술은 굉장한 수준까지 올라온 거
같습니다.
>> 예 그렇습니다.네 네. 그 왜
99점에서 100점까지 가위가 조금
겁난한 거 같습니다.
>> 제일 어렵죠.
>> 예.
>> 자, 테슬라 주가 동향도 알아봤고
그다음에 반도체 최근에 필반 지수
종목별 등략 이런 것도 다 받고
어 시장 자체는 지금 익스트림 피어로
가는
>> 예. 조금 희한한 시장이 연출되고
있습니다.
>> 최근에 SP 500이
>> 5일 동안에 뭐 2% 빠지고 나스닥
4.6% 빠지고 한 달 동안에
5.1% 1% 빠졌고
>> 예
>> 최근에도 그렇게 약해 보이지는 않는데
시장에 대한
>> 심리가 심리랑 여러 가지 변동성을
가지고 만든
앤드 인덱스는 지금 익스트림 피어에
있고
>> 그렇습니다. 우리나라 코스피도
브코스피가
희한하게
지수가 높여 나오는 그런 현상들이
나오고 있습니다. 어 그럼에도
불구하고 지금 10년물 국채금이는
4.4%가 깨지면서 4.37까지
떨어진 거
>> 네
>> 고무적이고요. 유가도 69.4까지
떨어져 있는데
그런데 왜 시장은 좀 기분 좋게 못
올라갈까? 요게 요즘 시장에
투자 참이
시장에 참가하고 있는 분들 입장에서는
>> 답답한 그런이
>> 나오고 있는 거 같습니다. 한쪽이
너무 강하고
한쪽이 너무 다른 쪽에 너무 다
소회돼 있고 거기에 따라서 또
레버리지나 마진이나 뭐 이런 것들이
너무 쏠려 있다 보니까 그런 것들에
의해서 부작용이 단기적으로 세게
나타날 때도 있고 하니까 어 시장
참여자들은
심적으로 굉장히 불안감을 느낄 만 할
수도 있을 것 같습니다.
>> 예.
자, 그럼에도 불구하고이 바이오섹터를
보면
>> 어 굉장히 강하게 치고 올라가는 그런
모습이 또 보이고 있어 가지고
이게 완전히 약세장으로 들어가면이
바이오가 또 그렇게 올라가기 힘든데
또 바이오 쪽에서는
신고가 나는 종목들이 막 나오는
모습들이 나오고 있기 때문에이
섹터에 또 어 주도주의 변화가 있는
건가
뭐 이런 것도
>> 좀 살펴보고 있는데
이번 이제
2026년 상반기도 이틀 남았다고.
>> 예. 이틀 남았습니다. 참 상반기
동안 시장이 참 드라마틱했다 그죠?
예.
>> 네도 그러고
>> 가사단 했던 거 같습니다.
>> 바이오 좀 말씀하셔서 이렇게 SMP
업종별 500 업종별 바이오 그 건강
관리 섹터 보시면은 대체로 SP
500에는 어 큰 종목들이 많이
들어가 있잖아요. 존슨 존세 라이릴리
뭐 이런 쪽이다 보니까 아 일반적으로
생각하는 바이오하고는 조금 결이 다른
약간 올드한 그리고 이제 이익이나
어닝파워가 괜찮은
그 큰 종목들이 파마슈컬 종목들이
들어가 있다 보니까 PER 보시면은
18.6배밖에 안 합니다.
>> 그렇죠. 약간 필수 소비제 성격
>> 맞습니다. 예.
>> 예. 바이오에서
>> 예. 그래서 현금 창출 능력도 좋고
그리고 이제 그러다 보니까 가끔 직도
하고 배당도 꽤 괜찮고 그러다 보니까
어 신약 개발에만 의존하는 바이오 어
종목들하고는 좀 결이 다른 거 같긴
합니다.
>> 예. [콧방귀]
>> 자 그러면 국내 미국 시장은 여기까지
하고 아 밸류에이션 언더 말죠. 네.
최근 미국도 그렇고 우리나라도 그렇고
좀 조정 분위기인데 일주일 동안
SM이 2% 하락했고요.
아 2% 하락했고 10개월 보드
EPS 여기 오타가 있는데 1% 정도
상승했습니다. 그리고 YTD가
7.4% 어 상승했고요. 10개월
보드 EPS는 7 18.7% 7%
상향 조정됐습니다. 6월 26일
기준으로 PR 19.94배 94배
기록하고 있고요. PBR은 5.5배를
기록하고 있습니다. 어, SP
500의 PR이 이제 20배 밑으로
좀 내려간 상황이고요.
등락률 보시면은 지난주 뭐 전반적인
시장이 조정 분위기였기 때문에 대체로
하락을 했습니다. 그 가운데
아라릴리가 10%가 올랐고요. 버크
SA 1.9% 그리고 JP모건
1.2% % 어 시총 상위 종목
중에는 어 이런 것들이 좀 올랐고요.
그리고 나머지는 좀 조정
분위기였습니다.
이익 쪽 보시면은 다른 것들은 다
그냥 왔다 갔다 하는 그런 상황이고
어 마이콘 테크놀로지가 아까
말씀드렸던 대로 32.4%가
한 주 동안에 EPS 상향이
됐습니다. PR 보시면은 굉장히 다들
착해졌는데요. 아 Nv디아가
18.3배, 3배, 애플이
30.1배, 구글이 22.8배
마이크로소프트가 19.1배 아마존이
21.4배
로드컴이 22배까지 내려갔고요.
어 테슬라 176.8배,
메타 14배 마이크론도 8.2배까지
내려갔고 라이리 30배 버크 SA
25.2벨
기록하고 있습니다. 대체로 IT
쪽에서의 그 밸루에이션들이 앞자리가
좀 바뀌는 그런
어 좀 눌려진듯한 그런 모습들이
관찰되고 있는데 어 실적 프리뷰하고
진짜 실적이 나오면 약간 좀 다른
양상을 보일 것 같습니다. 어, 돈
많이 쓰면서 어, 돈 잘 버는
회사들하고 돈 많이 쓰는데 돈 못
버는 회사들 이렇게 간단하게 어,
갈릴 것 같은 느낌이 있고요. 그
섹터 흐름 보면은
그동안 좀 강했던 반도체, IT
커뮤니케이션 이런 주요 섹터가 약세를
기록했고 아 필수 이제 헬스케어,
유틸리티 홈빌더 홈빌더는 내
말씀드렸듯 금리가 좀 빠지면은 강세로
가는 현상이 있는데 아 지난 주에
빌더가 5.8%가
상승을 했습니다.
이패스는 아까 말씀드렸던 대로 어
피수 영향도 있었고 전반적으로 좀
무상향하는 추세이고요.
어 경제 지표 보시면은
이번 주에 케스실러 어 20개 도시
주택 가격 지표가 나오고 있고요.
잠깐 보면 한 0.9% 9% 정도
Yi로 집값 상승이 있을 걸로 예상이
되고 ISM 제조업 PMI 같은 경우
53.9를 9를 기록할 걸로 보고
있습니다. 근데 제가 볼 때는 지금
제조업 분위기가 괜찮기 때문에
센 좀 넘 넘지 않을까라는 생각이
있습니다. 그리고
아 7월 2일 목요일 날 고용 지표가
나오는데
실험률 같은 경우 4.3% 예상이
되고 있고요. 그리고
아 임금 상승률 같은 경우는 3.5
가 예상이 되고 있습니다.
그리고
그 비농업 고용자수 증가 숫자가
지난번에 17만2,000으로 굉장한
서프라이즈가 났었는데 이번에 11만
5천건으로 조금 그 둔화되는 어 그런
현상이
나올 걸로 시장에서는 보고 있습니다.
미국제 10년물 기대 인플레이션
장당인금차 하일드 스프레드. 미국
6채 10년물은 8b락한 4.37%.
미국체 2년물은 어 8b 역시 하락한
4.09%. 장단기 금리차 28b.
어 기대 인플레이션은 6bp 하락한
2.2% 그리고 실질 금리가 2bp
하락한 2.16%입니다.
하일드 같은 경우는 7bp 상승한
6. % 파일드 스프레드는 17vP
상승한 2.83%를
어 기록 중입니다. 지난주에 아무래도
증시가 좀 조정 분위기다 보니까
하일드하고 하일드 스프레드가 조금씩
올라가는 현상이 관찰됐습니다.
상품 시장 보면은 유가가 70불
아래로 빠졌는데 아 지난주에만
10.5% 하락한 69.2불
기록했고요. 구리 같은 경우는
2.9% 하락한 6.14불
불 그리고 미국의 천연가스는 2.6%
상승한 3.28불 유럽 천연가스는
2.4% 하락한 41.09유로인데
대체로 어 천연가스 같은 경우는
미국이나 유럽이나 좀 바닥권에서
등락하는 상황이라서 큰 의미는 없을
것 같고요. 달러 인덱스 보면은
101.36을 기록했고요. 지난주에
0.5% % 상승했습니다. 주요국
토가 보면은 달러가 강세라서 그런지
조금씩 약세로 같더라고요.
달러 원 한율은 0.5% 상승한
1535.2원.
그리고 유로 달러 같은 경우는
1유로당 1.138달러를
기록했는데 지난주에 0.8% 정도
하락했고요.
달러엔 N 같은 경우는 0.28%
상승한 1달러에 161.73N을
73N을 기록했습니다. 160N을
조금 넘어서 어 거래가 되고 있는
상황이고 엔화 약세가 계속되고 있다고
보시면 될 것 같습니다.
어 코스피 보면은 최근 일주 하락폭이
좀 컸는데 7.1% 하락했고요.
12개월 포워드 EPS는 2.3%
상향 조정됐고
YTD로 코스피가 99.6% 6%
상승을 했고요. 12개월 4 EPS는
156.1%
사용됐습니다.
6월 26일 기준에 PR은 7.8배
그리고 PBR은 2.4배를
어 기록을 했습니다.
상승률 같은 경우는 대체로 그 하락을
했는데요. 어 현대차가 21.6%가
%가 하락을 했고 삼성물산이 하락 그
시장이 빠지는 가운데도 0.6% 어
상승을 했고요. 그리고 SK가
12.6% % 상승을 했습니다.
대체로 수급과 심리가 좀 많이 영향을
미쳤던 시장이었던 거 같아서
어 상승 하락폭이 어 많이 좀
종목별로 어 엇 깔리는 그런
상황이었던 거 같습니다.
이쪽 보시면 삼성전자가 2.5%
하이닉스가 4.4% 상향 조정됐고요.
나머지 그 SK 스퀘어 2.0% 0%
삼성전기도 6.4%나 사용
주정됐고요.
삼성 물산도 7.7% 사용됐습니다.
먼저 참고하시면 될 거 같고요. 어
보시면 아까 마이크론이 한 8배
정도에서 거래가 되고 있는데
삼성전자가 6.4배,
하이닉스가 7.1배에서 거래대가 되고
있고요. SKS에 5.7배,
삼성전기가 79.7배로 조금 어
내려왔습니다.
현대차 10.3 3배 삼성생명
23.4배
삼성물산 26.6배
LGN솔 89.8배 삼성 바이오
30.8배 현대중공업 17.8배
SK 5.9배 KB 7.7배를 7배를
기록하고 있습니다.
대체로 그 주가가 좀 하락하면서
조금씩 내려오는 모습들이 관찰이 되고
있습니다. 국내 금리 보시면은 주간
기준으로
국고체 10년물이 5bp에 하락한
4.11% 3년물이 6bp 하락한
3.72% 장단기금 이차가 어 42p
유지가 되고 있고요. 어 투자자금
중에서 어 투자자금은
1조 4,억 감소한 127조 기록하고
있고요. 실용자는
특별히 변화가 없었습니다.
38.1조를 조를 기록하고 있습니다.
주간 1평균 거래대금은 4조 정도
증가한 61조원입니다.
이번 주는
미국이 좀 거래수가 좀 짧고
또
삼성전자 아 실적 발표에 대한 때도
있고 미국
고용 지표나 뭐 이런 것들 좀 나올
거 예정이 돼 있는데 제가 볼 땐 그
아 매크로 쪽에서 크게 영향을 줄
만한 것들은
잘 모르겠고요. 다만 그이 지금
월말, 분기말, 반기말을 맞이한
상황에서
리밸런싱이나 뭐 레버리지 정상이나 어
포지션 정리 요런 부분들이 가면
갈수록 좀 마무리되면서
또 후반으로 갈수록 시장은 조금 어
안정되지 않을까 생각을 하고
있습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 예. 고맙습니다.
자 지금 보다 보니까 신용자가 38조
>> 신용자가 여전히 좀 높은 부분이 있고
주자의 타금은
>> 127조로 단단하게
계속 정시로 자금이 많이 유입이 좀
되다 보니까
>> 예
>> 뭐 총알은 아직 많다 이런 느낌이 좀
들고요. 10년물 국제 금리가 다행히
좀 빠지고 있어 가지고 다행이다는
생각이 들고 코스피 밸류에이션 지표를
보다가
>> 코스피 EPS가
>> 예
>> 1067원
>> 예 그렇습니다.
>> 그러다 보니까 8,400 지금 지인데
>> 예
>> PR이 7.8800
예,
>> 밖에 안 나오는데
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 얼마 전만 하더라도 작년에 우리나라
코스피 4월 달에 트럼프의 폭탄 관세
때문에 급락했을 때 [목을 가다듬음]
그때 2 2280이에요. 막
2,300 갔을 때도
>> PR은 지금하고 비슷했거든요.
>> 예. 그러니까 그때 EPS가 250
정도였다라는 말이잖아요.
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 아, 250이었다가
EPS가 지금 1천 넘으니까
>> 예,
>> 실제 우리나라이 규모 자체가 네배나
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 단한 겁니다.
자, 그렇게 이익이 큰 부로 증가했고
그러고 보니까 재작년에
재작년에 우리나라 코스피 다이바야
170조 벌었던가 작년이 1290조가
넘었고
>> 예
>> 재작년이 별로 못 벌었을까
>> 근데 지금은
900조 1천조 올해 900조
이렇게 예상하니까
실제로 이번에
우리나라 주를 끌어올린 가장 큰 동료
력은 머니머니 해도 이익 증가였다.
그죠? 예. 그렇죠. 예.
>> 실적 상세에서
>> 이익 증가로
이렇게 상승을 했다. 제일 이렇게
보는게 맞습니다.
>> 맞습니다. 제일 밑에 이제 YTD로
보면은 주가가 99.6% 상승했는데
이익 추정치가 상향된게
156.1%입니다.
>> 그것만으로도 뭐
>> 100% 이상 오를 자격이 있는
거죠.
그래서 산책하는 주인과 강아지에서이
주인이 156나
즉 벌써 쫙 뛰어갔고 그다음에 주가가
100m 정도 따라 올라 따라왔다.
그죠?
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 일단 주인이 계속 앞에서 연락이
되어가고 있습니다. 그런 모습을
보이고 있습니다.
달러 인덱스가 101.36 36 약간
올라온게 약간 좀 짐한 구석이고
하일드
스프레드가 살짝 머리를 드는 모습이긴
한데 어 추세 그 레벨 자체는
아직까지는
>> 낮은 레벨
>> 굉장히 낮은 레벨에서 그되고 있다고
보시면 됩니다.
자 그러면 어 국내 시장으로 넘어가
보기 전에 ISM 제조 PMI
>> 예 요게 7월 1일이니까
>> 예
>> 내일 모해 발표됐네요.
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 지금까지는이
예상치보다 계속
>> 좋았습니다.
>> 돌았거든요.
>> 예.
>> 그래서 53.9 구 예상인데 지난
달에 54였고요
부분은 또 좀 더 저도 올라가지
않을까
>> 그런 생각이 들고 ISM 제조
PMI랑 우리나라 포스피라 성관계수가
굉장히 높기 때문에 어떻게 나오는지
한번 잘 봐야 될 것 같습니다.
>> 왜냐면 최근에 최근에 2분기
그 GDP 확정치 나온 것도 보면은
지난번에 그 잠정치보다 한 0.4%
4% 포인트가 상향 주정됐거든요.
그때 그 이유가 어 그 케펙스에서
인프라 쪽에서 이제 좀 계속해서
견조한 모습을 어 보이다 보니까 그런
여행이 컸거든요. 그래서이 추세가 그
ISM 제조업 질수 좋아지는 추세가
저도 계속 이어질 것 같습니다. 네.
자, 그러면 국내 시장으로 넘어가
보도록 하겠습니다.
[목을 가다듬음]
지난주 금 시장 말씀드리겠습니다.
코스피 지수 5.8% 크게 하락으로
마감했었고요. 코스닥 시장이 4%
하락 마감했습니다. 수급적으로 보면
개인 투사자 8조 2,억대 순매수를
했었고요. 반면에 외국인과 기관의
매도세가 상당히 강했는데 외국인
투사자가 4주 6,억을 매도했습니다.
그리고 기관에서도 거의 4조 가까이
매도함했는데이
물량들을 개인 투자자가 좀 받아갔던
모습이었고요. 외국인 선물 쪽에서나
1조 4천억 가량 순매수가 유입이
됐습니다. 투자자별 매매 동향으로
보면 외국인 투자자가 삼성 전기
그리고 현대중업 LG 전자, 삼성
SDI, 주성 엔지니어링 등을 매수를
했었고요. 외국인 매도에는 삼성전자
2조 3천억 그리고 SK닉스도 2조
3,억 가량 매도하면서 두 종목
합산해서 4조 6,억 가량 매도가
나왔습니다. 그 외에는 삼성전자
우선주, SK 그리고 삼성 물산,
리가 캠바이오, 알테오젠 등을 매도를
했었고요. 기간 매수에는 삼성전기
그리고 SK 원닝 IPS PSK
현대차 LI DNA 등을 매수를
했었고 매도에는 SK하이닉스 2조
8천억 매도했습니다. 그 외에는
삼성전자 어 매도했고요. 나머지는
ETF 중심으로 매도가 있었습니다.
52주 신고가 종목 총 여덟 종목
나왔습니다. 어 코스피에서 광주신
세계 그리고 금모 건설이
신고가였고요.
코스닥은 PSK, VM, 기가미스
신고가를 기록하면서 반도체 소부장
흐름은 그래도 나쁘지 않았었던
하루였습니다.
그러네요.
근데 기관, 외국인이 삼성자,
하이닉스를 되게 많이 바르네요.
>> 네.
자, 반면에 외국인은 뭘 산더니
전기, 현대 중공업, SDI, 모비스
중공, 삼성중공
이런 것들 주성 엔진까지
그런 걸 사는 모습이고
외국인이 왜 또 생막게 곧 버스를 또
사네요?
>> 네. 한 300가량.
>> 자, 주요 기업들 동향 한번
보겠습니다.
>> 네. 금요일에 반도체 대용주 중심으로
좀 많이 안 좋았었던 하루였는데
애플에서 매물리 가격 부담으로 인해서
가격 인상에 대한 부담 토로를
했었는데 뭐 그런 영향에 향후에
빅테크 업체나 애플 같은 기업들이이가
메모리에 대한 가격 부담을 느끼게 될
거고 그에 따른 수요 둔화
있을 수 있다. 뭐 이런 이야기들이
금요일장에 좀 화제가 됐던 거
같고요. 어 삼성전자 5.3 3
SK가 8% 가량 크게 하락을
했습니다. 그리고 아래 소부장
종목들은 좀 혼조세였는데
상승했던 종목들 먼저 보면 HPSP
뭐 이오테크 파크 원익 IPS 등의
장비주들 나쁘지 않았고요. 밤에 리노
공업 그리고 주석 엔지니어링 ISC
심택 SNS텍 등은 또 약세 흐름을
보였던 거 같습니다. IT 섹터는
삼성 전기가 보합 정도로 마감을
했었고요. 이제 시장 대비로는 좀
강한 모습이었고 반면에 LG 전자,
LG 이노텍, BH, 파인 M텍텍
등이 약세로 마감을 했습니다. 플랫폼
섹터도 부진했는데요. 네이버 카카오,
뭐 카카오 페이 등 약세였고요.
디케이지 수도 크게 하락했습니다.
4% 급락이 나왔는데 여기도 반도체
소부장 쪽이 굉장히 부진했고요. 도쿄
일렉트론이 3% 가량 하락 마감했고
우라타가 9% 디스코 8% 이비된
어드반도
대략 다 8% 이상 하락하면서
일본 증시도 국내와 비슷한 흐름이
나타났습니다. 자동차 섹터 봐 주시면
뭐 현대차 기아 현대 모비스 오토에버
다 약세로 마감을 했고요. 거의 지금
한 달 내내에 빠지는 느낌 드는데
지금 원스으로
30% 빠졌습니다. 된 차가 많이
내려온 상황이라고 보여지고요. PR도
10열배까지 내려왔습니다.
소비자 섹터 봐 주시면 대용화장품의
LG 생권 와몰의 코스맥스 대체로
약세였고요. 코스메카 코리아가
3.4% 그래도 양호한 모습
나타났습니다. 피 미온 기기에서는 뭐
대체로 부진했는데요. 파마리서치를
제외하고는 다 약세였습니다. APR도
최근에 주가 많이 내려왔거든요.
그래서 4.7% 7% 하락했고 어
원스 기준으로도 한 6.8% 8%
가량 하락방 하락률 기록 중에
있습니다. APR도 지금 20회
초반까지
내려온 상황입니다. 그리고 나머지
종목들은 한 14배, 15배 정도의
거래가 되면서 상당히 낮은 밸류로
거래가 되고 있고요. 그리고 아래
음식률 섹터는 또 무진한 흐름
보이면서 3형식품도 2.8%
하락했습니다.
반면에 백화점이나 면세점 체인들은
나쁘지 않았습니다. 현대 백화점은
오히려 좀 상승하는 모습이 나타나기도
했었고요. 신세계는 좀 약보권 정도로
마감을 했습니다. 뭐 조선 차감이
기타 섹터 봐 주시면 조선주들도 안
좋았습니다. 현대 중공업 하나 오션
뭐 하나 엔진 등 대체로 다
약세흐름을 보였고요. 그까 하나
엔진이 15배까지
빠져서 현대 백화점과 밸류에이션이
거의 비슷한 수준까지 내려온
상황입니다. 유통 업체와 비슷한
[콧방귀]
수준이라고 봐 주시면 되고요.
그리고 전 뭐 포스 콜딩스나 LG
화학, LK 이노베이션, 정유 화학,
철강 대체로 다 안 좋았었고
하나 에루스페이스를 비롯한 방산주들의
흐름도 요즘 너무 안 좋습니다. 5%
빠졌고 넥도 오프고 현대 로템 7%가
급락이 나오면서 하나요는 20배가
됐고요. 로템도 16배. 뭐 넥스1은
35배까지
빠진 상황입니다. 그래서 반도체
소부장이나 반도체 섹터를 제외하고는
뭐 다 밸류 관점으로는 많이 낮아진
걸로 보여지고요. 지금 20배
미만에서 거래되는 종목이 성장주 중에
상당히 많이 보이는데 어 향후 한
3년간 20% 이상의 이익 증가율이
기대됨에도 불구하고 20배 미만에
있다는 거는 저평가 영역으로 들어간
종목들이 상당히 많이 보인다라는
생각이 들고요. 바이오섹터도 많이 안
좋았습니다. 코스피 바이오를 비롯해서
뭐 코스닥도 대주로 급락하는 모습이
연출이 됐었고요. 증권주도 뭐 키움
증권 목요일에 좀 반등이 강했던 걸로
기억이 나는데 금요일장에 바로
급락했습니다. 9% 가량 하락
마감했었고 엔터 쪽도 뭐 여전히
부진한 흐름 이어나가면서 뭐 SM은
열배입니다. 그리고 변합기 쪽도
장초에 좀 괜찮았었던 걸로 기억이
나는데 뭐 장 박판 들어가면서 다
하락을 좀 확대했고 현대 1렉을
비롯한 변합기도 많이 빠졌습니다.
그래서 현대 1렉 30른배 깨지는 거
보기 쉽지 않은데 깨졌습니다.
야이 조선철광 요쪽 섹터 지금 보는데
이게 한 달 기준이잖아요.
>> 네.
>> 잡게 돼 있는 거.
>> 네네.
와 많이 빠졌네.
그리고 뭐 증권도 보면 뭐 키움
증권뿐만 아니라 미래세 증권 이렇게
또 많이 빠졌어요. 최근에 보면
그죠.이
이 정권주가
보면 어떻게 보면 우리나라 금융자산이
계속 정권 쪽으로 이동을 하고 있는
그런 모습이기 때문에 약간 구조적
성장에 들어갔다고 더 볼 수가 있는데
주가는 뭐 지금 30%씩 빠져
있으니까
사실 제 마음속에는
그래서 얼마나 딱 하느냐? 저는 그
관점이라는 거예요. 이게 뭐
>> 정권주가
끝난게 아닙니다.
>> 그렇죠.
>> 만약에이 증권주 들고 계신 분들도
아마 많으실 건데 증권주가이
정도면 이제 밸루에이션을 따져 봐야
되는데 지금 키움 증거는 PR이 지금
PR이죠.
>> 다섯 배
>> 5.4배
>> 이러고 있고 KB 금융 7.7배 7배
뭐 요러 있는데 금융 이런 쪽은 별로
안 빠졌고요.
정권주가 최근에 이제 많이 빠졌는데
어 물려 있는 분들 입장에서는
어떻게 해야 되냐고 되게 고민이
많으시거는 거죠. 삼릭제하고는 요즘
거의 다
먹었던 거 다 토해냈다. 이런 말씀들
많이 하시는데 그 조선도 마찬가지
웬만한 종목들다
다 토해냈는데
전체적으로 보면 시장 분위기 자체가
약간 약한 모습
그 약한 모습이 뭐 이유가 뭘까라고
뭐 이래저래 따져봐도 최근에 뭐 전
세계 중앙은행이 약간 금리를 올리는
거 그거 말고는 사실 없어요.
>> 없는데
금리를 저번에 22년도에
금리를 5.5까지 쳐올리면서 신앙을
박사를 한번 냈다 보 냈었고 과거에도
79년도 80년대도 마찬가지고이
세드가 금리를 어디까지 올리느냐데
그때 별주부전에서도 한번 말씀드렸지만
이게 목욕탕 온도랑 생각하면 된다
했잖아요. 올리더라도 뭐 39도,
40도, 41도 정도까지만 올리면 아
따뜻하다 하면서 예 좋은데 이게
45° 46도 되면 앞뜨거하면서
튀어나올 수밖에 없나? 그래서 아
이거 금리를 올리는
피벗이 돼 버렸죠. 오히려. 예.
올해 들어와서도 한 두 번 더 내려지
않을까라고
올 초까지 기대했다가 오히려 금리를
올려야 되는 상황이 되다 보니까
거기에 이제 시장이 발발 떨면서
지금 하락을 하고 있기 때문에이
금리를 어디까지 올릴까라고 생각해
보면 실제도 10 16 10분 국제
금리가 먼저 성행해서 움직이는데
4.6 갔다가 지금 4.4가 가
깨지고 있기 때문에 이번에 금리
인상이 있더라도 결국은 이제 한두
번에 거칠 거기 때문에 이번에이
밸루에이션으로 매력 있는 주식들 예,
그런 주식들을 이제 좀 잘 찾아봐야
될 것 같고요. 바닥에서 그다음에 또
하나는 이게 24년도에도
8월 달에 조정이 있었잖아요.
그렇죠. 24년도에도 8월 달에 한번
앵캐리 트레이드 청산 어쩌고 하면서
다 빠졌었고 과거에 뭐 차정장세
한창 잘 나가다가 한 방에 이제 그
기세가 꺾였던게 2011년도 8월
달에 미국 신용등거 강등거든
그 약간요 8, 9월 요때 뭐가 많다
보니까
그래서 나스닥 100년 역사적으로도
보면 9월 달에 시장이 좀 안 좋았던
거. 그래서이 3분기에 대한 약간의
트라우마가 있어요. 그러다 보니까
거기다가 짝수에 도에다가 중간 선거도
있고 그러면서 지금 가상화폐 쪽도
이더리움 이런 것도 연초 이후 40%
이상 빠져 있거든요. 비트코인도
35% 빠져 있고.
그래서 약간 위험 자산 회피 심리가
특히나요
3분기에 대한 트라우마가 있다.
그렇게 저는 빠지고 그래서 어 최근에
여러 가지 뭐 중앙일보 제테크
방문남에도 있었고 계속
그런 강의가 좀 잡혀 있는데 제목은
하반기 주식 시장의 위기가 기
>> 그래서이 위기가 뭔지 그 부분이 제가
회색 쿠폴소가 금리라고 했잖아요.
근데 회색 고플수가 22년도처럼 막
우리한테 막 다가오면 뭐 빅테크든 뭐
할할 거 없이 막 70%씩 빠졌었는데
이번에 저 회색 보소가
다시 또 우리 쪽으로 돌진하느냐
아니면 저기서
>> 맨돌면서 평화롭게 풀만 뜯다가 가느냐
>> 어 근데 이쪽을 한번 쳐다보긴 해
중앙은행이 금리를 올리다 보니까 어
이쪽으로 한 한걸음 성큼 다가 선검
맞아요
다가선 맞는데 22년처럼
돌진하지는 않을 거다. 그렇게 예상을
하고 있습니다. 아 그러면 어 리포트
한번 보겠습니다. 삼성전자
리포트네요. LS 정우성 연구원이
남은 카드는 무엇인가?
내용 좀 살펴보면 CXMT 증서 오려
반기간 내 서버 디램 수급 영향은 좀
제한적이지 않을까라는 의견을 제시를
했고요. CXMTA 상장과 조달 기반
증서로 27년에 28년 디행 확대
우려가 부각이 될 수도 있다라는
전망을 했습니다. 다만 중국 업체가
15n 이하 공정을 확보하더라도
고성능 서버 디램 수급을 단기간에 좀
완화할 가능성은 낮다라고 보고
있고요. 서버형 디램은
미세공정구형뿐만 아니라 뭐 성능이나
전력 효율, 수율 고객 인증을 동시에
충족을 해야 된다라고 하고 중국은
이유비 장비를 확보하지 못한 가운데
첨단 노 장비 그리고 광학계 핵심
소재 등에서도 기술적 한계가
존재한다라고 합니다. 따라서
CXNT의 증설은 범용 디램 공급에
영향을 줄 수도 있겠지만 뭐 선단
서버 디램 시장에서 전자와 직접
경쟁까지는
상당한 시간이 필요하지 않을까라는
의견이고요.
AI 투자에 대한 미국의 정책적 지원
확대라고 하는데 미국에서는 국부 펀드
활용과 AI 기업 지원 확보 등을
통해 AI 산업의 성과를 공공히
공유하는 방안이 노인이 되고 있다라고
합니다. 아직 구체적인 제도나 자금
조달 구조는 확정되진 않았다라고
하고요. AI 인프라를 민간 투자를
넘어 국가 전략 산업으로 인식하고
있음을 보여주는 움직임으로
판단한다라고 하고 메모리 가격
상승에도 장비 수출 규제 강화나 가격
통제보다는 A 투자 지속을 지원하는
방향에 논의가 이어지고 있다는 점도
긍정적이라고 합니다. 인는 빅테크의
자금 조달 부담을 낮추고 매물리 어항
호조와 삼성전자의 장부가 질투적
기간을 연장하는 요인으로 작용할
가능성이 좀 높다라고 보는 거
같고요. 2분기 실적보다 HM의
양상성 확보가 핵심이라고 하는데
2분기 실적에는 1분기 중 상승폭이
제한적이었던 모바일 PCM 계약의
후행 인상과 성과학 관련 기조 효과가
저 함께 전망 반영되지 않을까
전망했고요. 이에 따라 단기 실적
개선은 지속되겠지만이는 현재 메모리
여항 호조에 따른 예상 가능한 이익
증가로 이미 시장이 상당 부분 주가에
반영하고 있다라고 보고 있고 결국
추가적인 초과 수익은 HBM 양상성
확보 여보가 핵심이라고 보고 있고요.
고객의 인증과 수선을 통해 H 확대가
확인될 경우 실적 추정치나 어 실적
추정치 사연과 밸루에이션 한 축소가
동시에 가능할 전망이다 의견을
제시했습니다.
CXMT가
어 상장 준비를 하고 있고 CXMT가
이런 자본 조달을 통해서 앞으로 뭐
장비 구입 증서를 통해 향후 디램에
대한 경쟁력 확보가 지금 시장에 약간
우리 반도체 입장에선 노이즈로 좀
작용을 하고 있는 거 같은데요. 일단
LS 증권의 정우성 연구원은
아직까지이 부분을 걱정하기 좀 이르다
전망을 한 거 같습니다. 그래서
추정치들이 조금씩 뭐 나오는 걸 보면
그 전에 송명서 연구님 자료 보니까
그 출혈량 기준 연도별 디램 시장
점유를 자료에 있더라고요. 산업
리포트 보면 전자가 26년 하반기
기준으로는 한 30% 33% 정도 또
추정을 하고 있고요. 스케이니스가
30% 그리고 마이크론이 한 27%
6% 정도 그리고 중국 쪽이 한
10%까지 올라올 것으로 보더라고.
그래서 중국이 어쨌든 점유 측면에서는
[콧방귀] 최근 한 2년 동안은 거의
5, 6% 포인트 정도 점유를
늘려가고 있거든요. 그런 부분을 보면
만약에이 AA 반도체 수요나 이런게
꺾였을 때 그럼 결국에 우리가 또
PC 모바일 이런 쪽을 봐야 된다는
거잖아요. 그러면 중국 쪽이 거기서
치고 올라온다.
좀 리스크 요인으로 향후에 좀 작용할
수도 있지 않을까? 근데 지금 구간은
아닌 거 같고 AI 수요가 워낙
탄탄하다 보니 그게 꺾였을 때 우리가
조심해야 된다. 그런 생각이 좀
들었고요. 아래표 보시면 블룸버그에서
제가 어 삼성전자 SK하이닉스
마이크로넷 케펙스 추위 그리고 향후
전망치까지 좀 넣어 놓은 건데요.
파란색 선이 삼성 전자고 그리고
하얀색이 SK 하이닉스 빨간색이
마이크론
보니까 마이크론이 케펙스 투자를 꽤나
많이 하더라고요. 거의 전자급으로
내년 되면은 할 것이다. 언제 추정이
되고 있는데 숫자가 작아서 잘 안
보이시겠지만 한 원화 기준으로 80조
정도 지금 어 블룸버그 추정치로는
나와 있다고 있더라고요. 케펙스
추정치가. 그리고 삼성전자도 한
80조 정도, SK하이닉스가 한
55조 정도 케펙스 투자가 전망이
되고 있습니다.
>> 근데 우 왜 이렇게 우하향이에요?
>> 아 이게 마이너스 그니까 투자잖아요.
케펙스 투자 다 보니까 마이너스
클수록 네네. 아 그 마이너스로
표기가 돼서 그런 거군요.
>> 그러니까 이만큼씩 계속 더 공격적으로
투자를 한다는 거네요.
>> 네. 올해가 한 40조 정도씩 하는
느낌이에요. 40에서 50. 그리고
내년 되면은 원래 상반기 한 초반에도
내년에 뭐 전자 한 5, 60조 정,
60조 정도 투자할 거다라고 추정치가
있던 걸 봤었는데 요즘 들어서 보니까
한 80조까지 늘어나는 [웃음]
나타나더
역시 투자는
이전 저희가 생각했던 거보다는 케팩
투자가 좀 더 활발이 일어날 가능성이
높
>> 올해
>> 내 내년입니다.
>> 내년 올해도 근데 추정치 대비 더
많이 투자하고 있긴 하거든요. 내년이
좀 더 그 폭 자체는 큰 거 같은데
그 연고님들 자료 보니까 한 27년
하반기 정도부터는
그 공급 부족이 좀 해소될 수도
있다. 뭐 이런 얘기를 하는데요.
일단 올해 기준으로는 아직까지는 어
수요 증가율이 생산 증가율보다 높은
상황이기 때문에 이런 부분은 걱정하진
않아도 되지만 내년에 좀 공급이
늘어나게 된다면 사기 그리고 20년
뭐 이렇게 되면 조심할 필요가 있다.
이런 이야기들도 최근에 뭐 산업
리포트에서 종종 나오더라고.
7월 말에 성경한다고.
>> 네. 그 지난주 금요일에 나오는
얘기가 지금 7월 1일 이번 주 목일
그 최종적으로 그 신고서 제주하고
그리고 다음 주부터 측량 시작합니다.
>> 네. 면적 그 기관하고 후에는 개인
>> 그러면 대충은 2주 정도 거릴 수
있잖아요.
>> 그 빠르면은 7월 마지막 주 20일
정도 그때
>> 어디 홍콩 시장 상장하는 거예요? 본
시장 중 어시
>> 본토에서
>> 맞아요. 근데 그 요통 시가 어 요통
주지수 그렇게 많지 않고요. 초기
그때는 아마 3%밖에 없어요.
>> 3%
>> 네. 요동할 수 있는 주식 매매
가능한 주식이고요.
>> 기관만 할 수 있고 개인을 살 수
없습니다.
>> 어 개인은 못 사고.
>> 네. 현후는 뭐 지수 편입 이슈도
있으니까 그래서 아마 시가 총에
변동성 좀 많이 커질 수 가능성이
있어요.
>> 왜냐면 원래는 1,300억이 나올 수
있잖아요. 1,300억. 어,
>> 내년은 2,억 정도, 내 후년은
3,억 정도 보고 있어요.
>> 뭐가? 순익.
>> 순익. 어, 3,억이
>> 3,억이면 60조.
>> 60조.
>> 60조인가?
>> 네. 60조. 2028년
>> 지금 그렇게 추정되었고요. 60조.
>> 네. 그때는 어떻게 되는지 한번 봐야
하고 뭐 중국 반도체 업체들이 PR를
부통 센시부터 50회 정도 받아요.
근데 그거 [목을 가다듬음] 미래에
비사하면
>> 그래서 여기서는 50회 적용하면
>> 어 350네
>> 거의 2천
>> 그렇네.네 네. 뭐 이렇게 계산하면이
나올 수 있어요.
>> 초기 그대는 요통주수 많지 않으니까
아마 선장일도 거의 무거 뭐 청종
이전까지 우라 가습니다.
>> 그러겠네. 오히려 유통 주수익수가
적기 때문에 매수세가 조금만 몰려도
주가가 좀 급등할 가능성이
>> 있고. 네. 내륙 시장은 10%가
상한가예요.
>> 아 이거 첫날이니까
>> 어 첫날은 적용 안 되고네 없습니다.
>> 그다음 날부터는 10%
>> 다음은 그 다음 다음 주 아면 이거는
과천반 선정하는 호사인가 그래서
상한가 하한가 플러스 20% 됩니다.
>> 아 플러스 마이너스 20%
>> 맞아요.
아이 창신 메모리랑 양 메모리만
아니면 사실
크게 무서울게 없는게이 삼성전자
하이닉에서 마이크로이 다 과화 해
놓고 있는데 앞단의 수요는 뭐 엄청난
수요가 지금 계속 한 앞으로 5년
동안 있는 거잖아요.
>> 그렇습니다. 그래서 걱정할게 없는데요
지금 창신하고 양점 해머리 상장으로
인해서이
케파 공격적인 케파 증설에다가 어
그래서 이제 법령 법령쪽 가격이
언제 무너지느냐 요게 이제 관건인데
뭐이
팀이나 이런 분들이
중국 반도체를 좀 쓰게 해 달라 뭐
이런 얘기를 했다고는 하는데 사실
중국의 내수 소화이도 바빠요. 그죠?
네. 뭐
>> 그래서 그 얘기는 사실 말이 안 되는
얘기고 뭐 남아두는데 우리가 뭐 너무
비싸게 팔면 아 중국거 쓸래 이게
되는 거지만
>> 예
>> 지금 전체적으로 뭐 중국에서 미국에서
다 추해지니까
아셨습니다. 또 여기는 또 앞으로도
계속 할 시간이 많으니까 넘어가도록
자 그다음에 현대 로템 리포트 좀
보겠습니다.
어 2분기 실적에 대한 이야기를 좀
했고요. 기대치네 기대치는 좀 부합할
것으로고 주카는 다시 박스권
하단이라는 제목이었습니다. 하나증권
자료였고요. TP는 28만
3,000원으로 제시를 했고는
매수인데요. 2분기 실적은 시장 컨센
정도 나올 것으로 보고 있고 폴란디안
KT 2차계 양산 매출 인식을
중심으로 디펜스 쪽 성장세가 지속될
것으로 본다. 자, 한편 동사 주가는
25년 하반기 16.5만 5만 원
28만 2,000원 박스권의 수준
움직이고 있다라고 하고이는 포워드
P순 기준 18배에서 28배 수준에
해당한다라고 합니다. 현재 주가는
다시 하단위 포드피 P 18배
수준까지 하락한 상황이고요. 금요일에
더 빠져 가지고 한 16배까지
내려왔습니다. 국내 방산 5사 중
가장 낮은 밸루에이션을 적용받고
있다라고 하고 최근 특정 섹터 중심에
주가 상승이 이어지는 시장 환경을
감안하더라도 방산 업종 내에 로템의
저평가는 결국 실적 우려가 반영된
결과로 볼 수가 있겠다. 디펜스
솔루션 부분 장군은 어 약
10조원으로 중장기 실적 성장에는 큰
무리가 없다라고 보고 있고요. 다만
납기 일정을 고려해 보면 27년
2분기까지 가시적인 방산 수출 성과를
확보해야지 단기실적 우려가 해소될
것으로 판단한다. 특히 단기적으로
가장 중요한 중동 수주 파이프라인은
수주 가능성보다는 시점의 문제로
판단하기 때문에 과도 우려는 지향해야
된다라고 이야기를 했고요. 그래서
이라크 쪽은 무조건 나갈 거긴 한데
그 타이밍이 언제인지 그걸 뭐 알 수
없다. 근데 어쨌든 이건 나올거다
이야기인 거 같고요. 2분기 이익으로
한 2,800억 정도 전망을 했고
컨센 정도 나올 것으로 봤습니다.
레일 솔루션이나 에코플랜트 부분 수주
장고는 각각 18.5조 0.8조 8조
정도라고 하고요. 핵시 사업부인
디펜스 쪽은 어 매출 1조로 전혀
대비 약 32% 가량 증가할 것으로
봤습니다. 여기는 폴란드한 K천차
2차 양산 매출인식 확대에 좀
기인한다라고 하고이 기준으로는 한
2,890억 정도 영업률 17%로
각각 전 대비 11.9% 9% 증가
1.1% 포인트 하락할 것으로 보고
있습니다. 상반기까지는
폴란드 2차 그 현지 생산 때문에
비용을 열어 잡아 놨는데 그런
수익성이 2분기 정도까지 이어질
것으로 보고 있고요. 어 반면에 한
4분기로 넘어가기 시작하면 2차
물량에 대한 마신도 이전처럼
계단식으로 좀 올라올 가능성이 높다는
전망들이 최근에 대다수입니다.
루마니아 전차 이야기도 했는데요.
아직 진척은 좀 없다라고 하고 현재
진행형이라고 합니다. 로마니아 전차
사업이 한 9조 정도인데 어 대형
사업으로 이라크 페루 사업과 함께
로템의 핵심 수주 모멘텀으로 볼 수가
있고요. 어 25년 9월 루마니아
국방부가 의외의 사업승인 요청을
제출을 했었고요. 지난 1월 이후
S출 대상 프로젝트 목록에서는 전차
사업까지는 좀 포함되지 않았다라고
하고이는 이유 대출 활용 시 현지
생산 조건 측면에서 상대적으로 분리한
독일 업체보다 로템 매수 주기대감을
높이는 요인으로
>> 볼 수가 있다라고 합니다. 뭐이 아직
구체적인 진척은 없다라고 하고요.
현재 루마니아는 후보 전차를 검토
중인 것으로 파악을 하고 있는데 어
6월 루마니아는 라인 메탈과 57억의
어 전투 차량이나 뭐 방국 체계 탄약
현급 계약을 체결했다라고 하고 이유쪽
대출을 활용한 이번 계약으로 라인
메탈이 루마니안의 현지 생산
네트워크를 선점하면서 뭐 전차
사업까지 독일 업체 유리하게 전개될
수 있다는 우려가 제기되고 있다고
합니다. 다만 이번 계약과 전차
사업은 별개로 추진되고 있는만큼 전차
사업에 미치는 직접적인 영향까진
아직은 제한적이지 않냐라는
이야기까지 했습니다.
아래 실적 추위 봐 주시면 뭐 매출액
이익, 영업익률 이렇게 분기별로
나오는데요.
어, 2차 물량에 대한 영향이 어,
지난해 한 4분기부터 시작해서 올해
1분기 이렇게 나오고 있는데 영업
이익률 추위만 봤을 때 지금 좀 좋지
않은 흐름이에요. 분기별로 계속
내려오고 있기 때문에. 그래서 10
[콧방귀] 지난해 2분기 18.2
그다음에 17.1, 16.5,
15.4 3 4 2분기에는 그래도 좀
반등이 나올 것으로 현재 추정을 하고
있는 거 같고요.
3, 4분기 가면 더 마진이 회복할
것으로 보고 있는데 아까 말씀드린
대로 이제 폴란드 현지 생산도 반복
생산 이런게 되다 보니 이전보다 좀
비용이 통제가 가능하지 않을까라는
전망이 녹아져 있다라고 볼 수가
있고요. 오른쪽은 뭐 실적 추위
그래프화된 모습이고 연간 부분별
매출액 추위및 전망표인데 디펜스
솔루션의 매출 비중은 여전히 계속해서
증가하는 흐름이 나타나고 있는
상황이고요. 레일이나 뭐 에코플랜트는
저 정도로 유지가 되고 있습니다. 그
아래는 하나 에어로 그리고 넥스원
현대 로템의 피수인데요.
첫 번째가 하나 요로 스페이스
하얀색입니다. 하얀색 하나 여로도
지금 많이 빠진 상황이고요. 그리고
현대 로템이 빨간색인데 뭐 17배,
18배까지 내려온 상황. 그리고
에라이 X1도 아, DNA도 한
35배 정도로 많이 내려왔습니다.
그래서 이익 증가분 대비 확실히 벨수
자체가 크게 내려와 있고요. 그 라인
메탈의 주가는 뭐 이전에 좀 선행해서
먼저 빠졌어요. 반토막이 났기
때문에. 지금 로탱과 하나 에어로나스
DNA도 같이 좀 내려오는 흐름이
나타나고 있는게 아닌가? 그래서
글로벌 방산 업체들의 밸류 자체가
조금 내려오다 보니 어쩔 수 없이 좀
동반해서 빠질 수밖에 없었고 또
반도체 쪽으로 대한 수급이
워낙 쏠리다 보니 더 영향을 많이
최근에 받고 있지 않나 그런 생각이
들고요. 그래서 만약에 이제 저희가
우려했던 그런 부분들 때문에 반도체가
쉬게 된다 혹은 약세로 전환하게
된다라고 하면
저는 사실 뭐 당산 그리고 그 화장품
쪽 AP
이런 쪽이나 아니면 2차전지요 정도가
좀 향후에 좋지 않을까? 만약 방
쉰다면
>> 그런 생각을 좀 하고 있습니다.
>> 그
>> 거 그게 보통 이제 방송에서는 많이
질문하는 건데
>> 반도체 다음 섹터는 뭐가 유망해
보입니까? 뭐 이런 질문들 늘 하는데
>> 그런 얘기까지 해 주셨고 어 저는
지금요 현대로템하고요 차트들 쭉
보면서 지금 거의 6개월 쉬고
있죠?네 네, 맞습니다.
>> 작년 우리가 한 7월 온절이에 주식
비중 좀 줄일 때 그때도이 줄이기가
좀 줄이는게 맞나 했었때 했었던
이유가 구조적 성전주잖아.
>> 음.
>> 광산 구조 성전주잖아요. 그죠?
조선도 마찬가지고 이번에 어 조선
업사이클 플러스 마스카가 붙은 건데
그러면 그 구조적 성장주를 가지고
장기 투자하는 분들은 어 되게 아우씨
이거 주가가 옆으로 기니까 좀
답답하실 거예요.
>> 네. 근데 장기 투자하는 분들은 그
진짜 구조적 성장조를 한 5년 10년
들고 가서 크게 먹는 분들은 요렇게
안 가는 국면에서도 버티고 있는
거잖아. 네. 어 버티고 있는 건데
모멘텀 플레이하는 사람들 입장에서는
조선 좋을 때 조선 갔다가 반도체
좋을 때 반도체 갔다가 그리고 다시
조선 돌아오려고 딱 봤더니 주가가 저
위에 다 있으면 좀 소픈데 어 봤더니
반도체 산다고 또 많이 또 우
몰려가다 보니까 조선이나 이런 것들이
또 고점 대비 지금 뭐 40%씩
35% 뭐 40%씩 빠져 있으니까
그 모멘텀 플레이를 잘하는 사람들
입장에서는 이놈 갈 때 여기 가서
먹고 저놈 갈 때 저기 가서 먹고
그럴 수 있는 건데
그래서
한편으로는이
가격적인 메리터가 되게 있다 보니까
>> 근데 그 변곡점이 언제 나오느냐가
중요하죠. 이런 거점. 작년에는
7월, 8월, 8월 달에 시장의 약한
조정이었고 그리고 9월 달부터 이제
반도체가 치고 올라가면서 어 주도주의
배가 생겼어요. 어떤 사람들은 계속
어 주도주 처음 주도주가 끝까지
주도주다.이 얘기도 많이 하는데 처음
이번 고금리 상황에서 실적 주도주는
조반으로 시작했죠. 그죠? 요
방산으로 시작을 했고 그다음에 이제
반도체가 치고 올라가면서 반도체 이익
모멘텀이 엄청나게 나오다 보니까
반도체 가능이라는
그 과정에는
결국 반도체가
계속 이익 증가가 계속 가파르게
넣으면 계속 반도체가 갈 거예요.
이익 증가율 순서대로 나열를 했을 때
제일 좋은 놈 쪽으로 돈이 쏠려게 돼
있으니까.
근데 그 이익 증가율이 이제 떨어지는
순간 어 이쪽이 좋아하면서도 그쪽이
치워가고
그러면서 뭐 삼성 전기 이런 것도 막
올라간 거잖아요.
>> 그 조선의 왕자 우리 선구 매니저를
여기서 소환을 한번 해 봐야죠.
>> 네.
그 다른 것보다도 이걸 언제 요쪽으로
갈아타야 되느냐 그 질문보다는
계속 작년에 봤던 그 성장 스토리는
계속 유지되고 있는 거예요. 아니면
뭐가 훼손이 돼서 지금 주가가 이렇게
지지분유를 한 거예요? 그 확실히 그
미국 쪽에서 군함을 만들어 주는
모멘텀 같은 경우에는 많이 소멸이
된게 맞을 것 같긴 합니다. 왜냐면은
어 원래는 작년 연말에 그 국회
이후에서 통과
>> 상원에서 그죠.
>> 예. 통과가 될 걸로 예상을 했었는데
>> 사실 그 작년 말에 통과가 안 된게
가장 큰 첫 번째 이유인 거 같고
>> 그리고 또 지난주에 또 탈락을
했거든요. 근데 그렇게 되면은
>> 어 미에서 좀 어느 정도 모듈을 제가
제작하고 그리고 미국 쪽에다가 이제
보낸다면 암제품을 만들어야 되는
스토리였었는데 그건 확실히 어 거의
없어진게 맞다라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 다만 그 저희가 전혀
예상하지 못하고 있었던 데이터 센터
쪽으로 엔진 나간 같은 경우에는 저
오히려 미군보다도 훨씬 더 큰
시장이다라고 생각을 하고 있거든요.
새로운 마켓을 열렸는데 미구남은 사실
저희가 그렇게 되면은 마진이 얼마가
나올지 아니면 시장 규모가 어느 정도
될지 전혀 예측하기가 좀 불가능한데
엔진 시장 같은 경우에는 어느 정도
예측이 가능하고 마진이 확보가 돼
있는 사업이다 보니까 그 군난보다는
엔진 쪽으로 좀 노려보는게 더 나은
상태일 수도 있을 것 같습니다.
>> 그렇네요.
>> 거기 마스가라는
또
어 멀티플이 붙어었는데 그죠?
미국 군함을 우리가 다 만들어 줘야
돼. 그 스토리가 그 조선에 있어서
국가에 반영이 됐었는데 그 거품이 싹
거쳤다라고 보내 되는 그죠. 그
거품은 이제 거쳤고 그러면 그냥 실적
대비해서 PR이 지금 얼마 받는가 그
부분만 보면 되는데 지금은 그
마스가에
대한 부분을 제외하고 보면 그러면
조선 밸류에이션은 어때요?
어, 확실히 그 마스카라고 그 껴
있을 때는 그 조선주들이 30배를
정확하게 딱 지키면서 계속
올라갔었었거든요. 근데 대부분 지금
다 20배 언더까지 떨어져 있기
때문에
>> 어, 저는 만약에 그 엔진 모멘텀이
저 확실하게 나올 거다라고 생각을
하고 있거든요. 왜냐면은 이미
궁장까지 어, 증설 스케줄을 열린 거
보면은 그 수주를 기다리고 그냥
조금씩 모아가는 전략은 괜찮지
않을까라고 생각합니다.
>> 예.
반도체가 못 갈 때 조방으로 또 먹고
반도체 갈 때 반도체로 먹고 이번에
다시이 얘네들 갈 때 얘네들도 먹고
해 주면
>> 어 그러면 뭐 최고다 그죠.
>> 예.
그렇게 최고가 될 수 있도록 [웃음]
매니저들 많이 노력을 해 주시기
바라겠습니다. 자, 그러면 국내
리포트는 여기까지 봤고요.
현재 로템 같은 경우도 진짜 아까 그
빨간색이었는데 그죠? 어, 상당히
멀티플 진짜 밴드 밴드 하던 거지
지금 빠져 있. 네, 맞습니다.
>> 알겠습니다. 자, 국내 시장 어떻게
되고 있습니까? 아까 보니까 야간
선물은 -0.57
>> 어 사우스 코리아의 ETF는
-3.77은
금요일 시장을 후행해서 반행한 반영한
거고 야간 선물은 약보합으로 끝났는데
어떻게 하
>> 어 - 0.91%로 하락해서
출발했고요. 현재는 -1.73%까지
하락폭을 좀 더 키우고 있습니다.
>> 네. 코스닥은 어떻게 되고 있을까?
>> 네. 코스닥 플러스 1.06%로
상승해서 출발했고요. 현재는
4.6%까지
>> 4.6%요.
>> 네. 어,
>> 큰폭으로 지금 모르고 있습니다.
>> 어, 지난주 신차 분석하면서 코스닥은
단기 바닥은 진 거 같다. 그래서이
갑작스럽게 코스닥에 뭐 바이오주도
올라가고 뭐 이런 모습들이 기술적으로
보니까 시장 자체가 코스닥 시장
자체가
>> 20개월이 평성 건처까지
빠졌더라고요. 그 정도 빠지면 반팔
매수가 들어오는데
야 4% 나오려고요.
이런 부분들이 그 금리가 10년부
국채 금리가 4.5 이상일 때는 뭐
반도체 빠져도 코스닥도 더 빠지고
그랬잖아요.
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 근데 금리가 4.4 이해하로 좀
떨어지다 보니까
반동체 빠지면 오히려 이제 요쪽이
올라가는 실속 게임이
>> 시작되는 거 보면
아까 제가 말씀드린 대로 금리
공포에서는 조금씩 약간 오히려
안도감을
느끼는 시장이 앞으로 좀 되지 않을까
그런 생각도 듭니다.
자, 그러면 오늘 밤 미국 시장을
예상을 해 볼 건데 지난주에는
어 미국 시장 다 마이너스 난다라고
다 예상을 했었네요. 보니까.
>> 다 마이너스 아니었어요?
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 어, 다 맞췄네.
>> 대단하십니다. 다스
이번 오늘 밤은 어떻게 됩니까? 오늘
밤은 SP랑 나스닥 둘 다 상승할 거
같은데.
음.
선물에서는 나스닥이 지금 좀 더
오르고 있는데
SMP가 좀 더 오르면서 끝나지
않을까라고 생각이 듭니다. 이유를
생각해 보면은 나스닥 안에서 그때
주말에 별주 부정할 때 베타 개념을
설명했었잖아요. 그래서
>> 네.
>> XLK랑 SMH라는 ETF로 좀
나눠서 봤는데 SMH가 좀 더 베타가
큰 종목이라 하더라고요. 반도체.
>> 어. 근데 SMH가 좀 더 많이
빠졌는데 엑셀보다
선물에서 지금 SMH가 오르는
상승폭이 좀 덜 제한적이라서
안도체 쪽에 매수 탄력이 생각보다
약한 거 같아서 나스닥 좀 왔다 갔다
하다가 SP가 결국은 좀 더 많이
오르지 않을까라고 생각합니다. 어
유리프로가 월라수목 아침마다 저거
하고 또 토요일 날 별 주분까지 하다
보니까 어 시장에 대한
관심과 집중도가
엄청나다는 생각이 드네요. 지금
시장에 대한 설명을 하는데
SP 500하고 나스닥이 어느게 더
강할지 이런 것까지 구체적으로 일단
둘 다 오른다.
필반은 어떻게 될 거 같습?
>> 상사할 것 같습니다.
>> 필반
>> 또 하루 쉬었으니까 또
>> 이틀 쉬었나요? 하루
>> 쉬었나요? 8 쉬었습니다. 8월
쉬었는데 낙폭 자체가 너무 심해
가지고 상상할 것 같고요. 일단 그
반기 말이다 보니까 어 기관 투자자들
같은 경우에 이제 성과가 상당히 갈릴
텐데 성과가 안 좋은 기관 투자자들
같은 경우는 주도주를 좀 적게 가지고
있을 것 같고 소외주를 많이 가지고
있을 것 같은데
약간 그 뭐 약간 좀 그 성과에
압박을 받는 기관 투자들은 주도주를
좀 팔고 어 소외주를 좀 사면서 자기
포트를 약간 윈도우를 드레싱하려고
하는 그런 수요가 있을 것 같습니다.
그래서 제가 볼 때는 오늘 코스닥도
약간 그런 모습들 때문에 그런 그런
니즈들 때문에 어 좀 더 상승폭이
세게 나타나지 않나 싶고요. 미국
같은 경우도 보면은 최근에 소해주들이
좀 어 좀 강한 그런 모습들을
보이는게 윈도우 드레싱 월말 분기말
반기말 윈도우 드레싱 수요가 있을 것
같아 이제 그게 오늘 내일 이렇게
지나고 나면은 저는 좀 약해질 거라고
보고 있거든요. 근데 반도치 지수가
금요일 날 세게 빠지고 다른 이제
소유수가 많이 오르다 보니까 어느
정도 그 수요가 좀 마무리되지
않았을까 하는 그런 생각이 있어서 어
반도체 지수 너무 많이 빠진 거에
대한 반발 매수 또는 반등이 좀 있지
않을까라고 생각합니다.
>> 사실 최부 사장님이 반도체 집에서
너무 많이 빠진 거라고 얘기했는데
>> 예. 너무 많이
>> 봐신
다른 섹터랑 비교하면
>> 어 그렇게 말씀하시면 안 되지 다른
사람들은 아 뭐 그럴 거예요. 아니,
지금 여기 옆에 보면 뭐 아까 하나
엔진 - 40% 빠져 있고 지금
>> 예, 다른 섹터도 초토가 돼 있는데
>> 하루 -5% 빠졌다고 너무 많이
빠져서 지금 반도체 그 반등
>> 그런 얘기하시면
[웃음] 다른 사 다른 지금 섹터도
막 공상자들이 막 지금
수풀에 있거든요.
>> 아, 말 조심해야 되나?
자 그러면 예
>> 코스닥
가보겠습니다. 코스닥 그때 뭐 계속
음봉 음봉 얘기했었는데 오늘은 이제
양봉 아니에요? 밥 나온 거
아니에요?
>> 아 오늘 설자 설자 점수가 분위가
>> 어 점수는 음봉 나왔을 것 같아.네
네, 맞아요. 그런데 전보다는 많이
나아졌어요.
>> 아,
>> 많이 나아졌어요.
>> 음봉에 대한 확률이 점수가
>> 네. 네. 맞아요.
>> 오늘은 뭐 난 양봉 [웃음]
>> 어, 너무 확실한 확실하게 보여서
>> 네.
>> 수단 양봉.
>> 자, 코스피는 어떻게 돼요?
금요일. 금요일임에도 불구하고
잠깐만. 그때 양봉 금요일
아 음봉이었나?
아 음봉이었네
금요일고
오늘은 지금 애매하다 그죠?
[콧방귀]
>> 10초가 -0.9로 9로 시작했는데
벌써 2% 하락
>> 기록 중에 있거든요.
>> 외국인이 지금 1조 3,800억을
때린 걸로 여기 네이버에 나오는데
맞아요?
>> 네. 1조 6,700억 정도 지금.
>> 어,요 10분 지연이니까.
>> 네.
>> 외국인 매도세가 좀 세네.
>> 반도체 때리는가요?
>> 네. 삼성여자 하이닉스 거부장이
진짜 좀 강해 가지고 반도체 좀
반등이 장중에 나올 수도 있다라는
생각이 들긴 하는데
소부장이 강하고 메모리는 약한 거는
나는 약간 이제 창신 메모리 상장
가시권이 들어서면서
>> 어차피 청시는 공격적으로 캐터
정설할 거니까 소부장은
약할 이유가 없잖아. 그렇죠.
>> 근데 창신이
어 지금 오래 들어와서 디램 점유율이
거의 8%인데 어
>> 네. 내년에 10% 넘어가는 거는
그거는 뭐 삼성이나 다른 데서도
그거는 당연한 거다. 왜냐 뭐 중국
내 수요만
>> 다 해도 캡티브 마켓 자체가 큰데이
>> 10% 넘어가는 건 당연한 건데 그때
20%까지 목표로 하는게 어느 시점이
언제
>> 어 2028년 후
>> 28년 후에는
>> 네네 후
>> 어차피 증선하고 생산 안 된 뒤까지
시간이 걸리니까
>> 맞습니다. 예.
>> 그러면 28년에는 20%가 가능할까
생각해 보면 저는 가능하다고
생각해요. 왜냐면 중국은
>> 자기네 거 쓸 거니까. 배터리도
그랬었잖아. 배터리도
SDI하고 LG 화학에다가 훨씬
기술적 우유에 있는데도 보조금 안
주면서 배터리도 그랬으니까. 28년
되면 20% 된다고.
그런 거에 대한 약간 이제 두려움
그런 게
>> 창실 메모리 상장대까지는 좀 영향을
주는 거 아닌가?
>> 단지 하이닉스 같은 경우에는 ADR
상장권이 있는데 근데요 ADR 건도
마이크론이 계속 빠져 버리면 또 할
말이 없는 거예요. 그죠?
[목을 가다듬음]
마이크론하고 계속 이렇게 상대적
비교를 하면서 마이크론이 밸류에이션이
훨씬 더 멀티플이 높게 되더니
>> 그래도 ADR 상장 때까지는 그래도
예수
반발 저기 저가 매수세는 계속 들어올
거 같아요. 기댈 언덕이 두 개나
있으니까 ADR 상장이고
7월 말에 본실적 발이고
>> 실적이 일단 쫓게 나올 거니까
>> 음봉해 보겠습니다. 일단 오늘은
>> 코스피 음봉
>> 네
>> 아니 너무 계속 시간 끌다가 지금 한
거 아닙니까? 아, 저 말씀드리려고
했는데
>> 아, 내가 계속 얘기 [웃음]
>> 난 사실 어, 생각할 시간을 좀
준다고 하긴 했는데 아,도 사이에
시장이 더 빠져 가지고 [웃음]
그러면 코스피 연보 예상을 한다고
얘기했습니다.
그게 항상 주식이 변동성이 큰
자산이라는 거 우리가인지를 해야 되고
근데 변동성하고 추세는 다른 거예요.
그죠?
>> 맞습니다.
>> 예. 그래서 어 변동성을 맞추려고
하는 거는 저도 참 변동성이 예상을
해 보지만 정말 맞추입니다. 음.
>> 그것보다는에
추세를 맞추는게 더 맞는 거 같고
>> 그런 부분에 있어서 추세는 어떻게
결정이 되냐 그거는 뭐 우리 최부
사장님이 매일 아침마다 어 실적 리뷰
프리뷰 해 주고 실적 나왔을 때
체크해 주고
>> 그다음에 걔네들이 또 앞으로 다음
분기 어떻게 될 건지
>> 예
>> 그게 실제로는 펀더멘탈이
가는 방향이니까
그 추세 속에 나타나는 변동성까지
우리가 잘 이해를 하면 싸게 살 수
있는 기회가 되고 비싸게 팔 수 있는
그런 기회가 되는 거기 때문에이
변동성을 잘 어 이겨내시고 계속
저희는이
펀더멘탈
훼손이 없는지 이런 거 잘 체크하도록
하겠습니다. 그죠?
>> 예.
아 이번 한 주도 어 마무리
잘하시고요. 상반기 마무리 잘하시고
또 새로운 하반기가 시작되는 한주니까
저희 최선리 투자하는 분과 함께 어
행복한 투자 슬기로운 투자 계속
이어나시길 바라겠습니다. 인시간
함께해 주신 여러분 고맙습니다.
감사합니다.